good morning members members of the
public
and members of the public watching on
the youtube stream this morning
my name is robert carmichael i'm the
governance officer for baylor
mid-suffolk district council and
mid-suffolk development control b
this morning i'll run you through the
order of proceedings of
the arrangements and domestic
arrangements as the chair is not here
as such we'll be taking an election for
the voter of election
for the chair at the start of this
meeting following going through the
regulations unless
members have wished to have the election
before i read out this point
but it would just mean that we'll go
through all the fire safety and
everything beforehand
if i don't hear any objections i'll
continue through this point
thank you so um may i please remind you
of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber
and in the communal areas please ensure
that you wear a face covering at all
times
unless you are sitting down or you are
exempt from doing so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
these are available at the back of the
room and there are masks available as
well
please ensure that you turn microphone
off microphones off when you're finished
and please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking if you are
attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and finally we'll be using the e-voting
this morning on the modern.gov app
so please members make sure that they
are logged in and ready to use the app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are
any confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
being recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and the
press are not lawfully excluded
i'll just do the introductions as well
that myself has already introduced we
have mr john paintman g as the area
planning manager
mr ian depray who is our planning lawyer
as well
and mr alex scott who is the case
officer for one of the other
applications this morning
so what i will propose to do is that we
will take a vote and then obviously
whoever becomes chair will take a very
short break
just to move them into this side of the
room and to run through any points
so councillor richardson can you start
stop
yes i'd like to propose councillor
passmore as chair for the meeting
thank you very much
is there a seconder for that
no so that i don't have a second for
that nomination could i please ask for
any other nominations
counselor andrew melon um yeah i'm happy
to nominate councillor stringer to be
chair of the meeting
thank you there is no secondary
councilor wendy turner
thank you so i will just update the vote
in one.gov
so members i will now start the vote and
council stringer could i take your vote
verbally please
counselor turn i could have just checked
it are you
thank you members all votes have now
been received and that is
three votes sorry four votes four
councillor stringer
one against and one abstention so
council andrew stringer is
chair for this meeting this morning as i
said i've just taken a quick break
manny so that we can just do a bit of
musical chairs
thank you
well good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to
the development control committee b here
at wednesday the 4th of august
we will be going through a two planning
applications today i think
uh you'll have to bear with me because
obviously this is the first
of these that i've chaired if i do get
anything wrong please put my hand up if
you think something is going awry
and i will do we will do our best to
make sure everyone gets heard
and everyone's point of view gets put
across uh
what i i need to read the filming
statement do i have you read that
you've already done that good right so
uh i think we do introductions to when
you've done the introductions
no sections okay right so
we move on to the agenda so could i have
apologies for absences and substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies this
morning from councillor mike norris
council of roman war boys
councillor barry humphries councillor
cast james carsten
counselor kathy guthrie and councillor
peter gould and substitutions this
morning our councillor tim
passmore is substituting for councillor
james carsten
councillor john field is substituting
for councillor mike norris
councillor wendy turner is substituting
for councillor warboys and councillor
harry richardson is substituting
for councillor barry humphries thank you
chair
thank you do we have any declarations of
pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interests
i would like to declare one from the
chair is i'm the county councillor for
the village of backton
that doesn't suggest where i should vote
just gives me a slightly
deeper insight into the highways issues
i thought i'd better declare that
any other declarations of lobbying i
think i think it's pretty i think
been lobbied on both applications i
believe
by many sides i think so i think we've
been lobbied
but yes to everything declarations of
personal site visits
i've certainly i can't not have a site
visit to turkey hall lane it's so close
to where i live
second one fell sure yeah okay
sorry just to check where was your site
visit counselor
melon application thank you
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 7th of july
any points of accuracy or amendments
things need to be clarified no
so could i have a proposer and a
secondary please to approve the minutes
council richardson happy too
i'll second from the chair if that's all
right okay
thank you chair we'll go to the vote
then on that so the vote
um is now in progress in modern.gov um
so if members go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner of their agenda
and go to the voting subsection
which will now show in blue council
string do you want
to receive notice of petitions in
accordance sorry tier we haven't
finished the vote yet we haven't
finished the letter
we have to be done
just waiting for one more i forgot how
slow modern technology is
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is
five votes for and one abstention so
that is carried
right to receive any petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received chair right we now move on
to the
schedule of planning applications so 7a
dc 210641 land to the east of turkey
hall lane backton
could i invite the case officer alex
scott to introduce the application to
the committee
thank you alex
thank you chairman um
members this is item 7a
in the papers application reference dc
21
00641 and it's land east of turkey hall
lane in backton
the application before you is reserved
mata's application
for consideration of layout scale
appearance
and landscaping of 51 dwellings
including 18 affordable homes
and this follows outline planning
permission approved by committee in may
2018.
the application was previously
considered by this committee
on the 9th of june of this year 2021
and was deferred for reasons relating to
design review
specifically surveillance of public open
space
and proximity of car parking to existing
properties at
north close and the changes
are set out in section 3 of the officer
report
so i hope that's clear and
onto the presentation
this is a the location of uh backton
within the district for the avoidance of
doubt
and the approximate location of the site
within the within the parish village and
and area
this is a constraints map
of the site the application site is
edged in
in red for you there uh the blue line is
the settlement boundary of the village
indicating it's a key service center
within the
current uh development plan and
uh if i can just use this pointer well
it's not very
well there it is yeah yeah sorry we've
got a
listed building here grade two
in close proximity which is probably the
key sorry
oh okay thank you very much yes yeah
that's much better okay so uh we have a
grade two listed building here at
uh turkey hall and proximity to the site
and um this is the uh the main
railway line which is also adjacent to
the site as well which are the key
considerations
and of course uh turkey hall lane
along here which is um
a rather narrow lane at present and
that will be the subject of
some discussions as we go through
this is an aerial map of of the site
again the application site edged in red
so that shows in photograph form for you
and we have the site location plan
site location plans as submitted with
the application um
formal planning application area
this is the proposed layout the current
layout revised from
last time it was uh before you this is
now revision
p19
and this is a zoomed in
view of the southern portion of the site
and the northern portion
and this just uh this just shows the
location of the
affordable dwellings here and i've got
some elevations
as we go through
so we have the um market
dwellings these are the detached market
dwellings
and we have included 10 bungalows
as in the proposal two designs
and these range between two and four
bedrooms
yeah we have just double checked that
share and a pencil i've just plugged in
and it's
it's all coming through fine as far as
we can tell
um you might just ask whoever's whoever
it is to check those settings on their
computer
um we've got independent people watching
outside of the meeting that can here as
well so
i just asked everyone if you can't hear
well you won't hear me now but
um to check your settings
it's okay it is working i'll just double
check
continue alex thank you um
yes for the the first elevations uh this
next slide is the
elevations of uh the semi-detached
market dwellings and these range
between two and three bedrooms
these are the elevations of the
affordable homes so we have
two apartment block buildings proposed
and the remainder are semi-detached
dwellings
and these are the garages which will
which are proposed in conjunction with
the uh
little layout and this
uh next slide shows the treatment of the
proposed pumping station in proximity
to turkey hall which is a
state begins approximately here
and we have a brick wall and
landscape screening to to that boundary
now this was the indicative layout
provided at an outline stage
and there have been some revisions
since then and i'll illustrate those
uh to you on the next slide so on the
left
we have what was indicated
at outline stage and on the right what
is now proposed at
reserved mata's details stage
and as you will see the key differences
moving the development back away from
turkey hall lane
addition of public open space
including a drainage feature and
um that means that the previous area of
public open space has been reduced
over here to the uh to the eastern
portion of the site
and these are some illustrative
artwork representations of how the
how the estate might look
just to give you an indication
and here i've tried to illustrate for
you
the differences um between the
layout now proposed at p19 and that
previously proposed a p18 at the last
committee so here we have north close
and
the adjacent residential property we
have one of the
apartment blocks and the parking as
previously
and one of the reasons for the deferral
was
concern regards impact on the amenities
of
um particularly the the closest
residents in terms of
uh parking and in order to resolve that
the applicant has moved the building
away from the site boundary and the
parking area
and added some uh some landscaping to
that boundary
so um
hopefully that addresses it certainly
your officer's opinion that it does
and we have some some distances for you
there
which have been provided in the last few
days by the
applicant in case there are any
questions or questions regarding
distances those are set out for you
there
and to the other matter the surveillance
of the
public open space to the to the east of
the site
um the the current uh
revisions have included uh further
windows
in the facing elevations of plots 31
and 32 where previously they were blank
and uh it felt that that would uh
create further overlooking
um positive overlooking of the public
open space and surveillance
um yes sufficient to address members
concerns
hopefully and now those windows they
serve
bedrooms upstairs and kitchens
and lounges downstairs and the middle
windows are
our small wc windows
and those revisions are in addition to
plots 21 through 24
which haven't changed as previously this
is the
fenestration layout in the in the rear
of those properties
again overlooking the
public open space and again for your
information
i've measured the distance between all
properties
approximately 10 meters in all cases to
the public open space
onto some photographs this is the uh the
top of
turkey hall lane
and moving down the lane showing the
existing
situation for you this is in front of
the site
you might be able to see the building at
turkey hall
in the distance and this is then looking
back
down turkey hall lane from turkey hall
across the site and these are the
existing properties fronting
north close
and there again and then just looking
around the site moving from
right to left
then towards turkey hall
and this is a slide which was considered
that
the previous committee at the top of
north close just showing the
relationship between the site
and the existing um pavement
and road relationship and is proposed to
put a
public uh footpath through that for
pedestrian access
right that uh concludes the um
presentation uh there are a few items in
the
uh in the table papers uh for you late
representations from
um uh from consorties for your
consideration
also um but as in the papers
uh on the basis of the revised layout
your officer's recommendation
is for approval thank you thank you alex
do we have any questions from members
councillor mellon
yeah thank you chad um i'm not quite
sure if this is a question for the
officer
or for the era planning manager or maybe
it could be even a question for the
legal officer
um we're obviously looking at reserve
matters here
but we have an outline application which
is contingent on
the widening of turkey hall lane to 5.5
metres as agreed
at outline um and i understand that that
5.5 meters cannot now be delivered
um so i wonder if discussion of
reserve matters is a moot point at this
stage
thank you john thank you
so you are looking at the reserve
matters you're looking at the
layout scale appearance of the buildings
and landscaping of the site
access was part of the outline
permission
that's dealt with and any access points
are all dealt with
in that context and ultimately the
widening of turkey lane road was part of
the outlying
permission you are correct they have
discovered at this moment in time
that they can't fulfill the um provision
of the plan
for 5.5 metres to widen
uh that road there is but they can go up
to 4.8 meters
as it's understood which allows a car
and a lorry to pass potentially
but it's not 5.5 which would allow a
lorry and a lorry to pass each other
um that is a problem for the outline
planning permission that they need to
resolve
and they have been made aware of that
we've met with the applicant
and discussed that point with them it
has no bearing whatsoever
on the reserve matters that are actually
before you today
if they cannot deal with the outline in
terms of that
provision they will need to seek to
either vary it
and that would be a separate application
for them to for us
to consider could come back here or they
may have to
completely look at a different way
around solving that problem
whether that means the reserve matters
you may or may not grant today
will ever go ahead because of that issue
is also a separate matter
but ultimately you need to deal with
this application on its merits before
you
could i just come back you said that the
access
had been dealt with the outline stage
yet at reserve matters we've now got a
change in pedestrian access
the access points for vehicular access
and should include pedestrian access
is part of the outline application any
point of access
but they have now changed in the outline
what have they changed in the outline
allergies well the original scheme
shoe footpaths in turkey hall lane
accessing this site
they're now coming off pound hill close
they've added an additional access
oh so so the footpath works are going to
be carried out in turkey all night
that at the moment they are part of the
outline permission and part of that
consent and again like i said if there's
amendments to that necessary
they would have to deal with that in
terms of their amendment to the outline
permission very helpful that's clarified
thank you thank you council possible
thank thanks um andrew just a couple of
some
small questions i think there was a
picture up there of the pumping station
i
imagine this to do with foul water
drainage because that was an issue
i don't know was it an existing one in
which case i was just wondering
if is there suitable landscaping around
it because if you're living in a house
you don't want a
thing like that right in your back
garden and not shielded and the other
one
i don't know whether this is relevant at
this stage but um
i know the points here are made that
they're content with the surface water
drainage
um i'm just quite interested to know
about driveways and so on are they
porous
etc because with all the talk there's
been over the last few years about
flooding and so on
we just need to be doubly sure in my
opinion uh personal view that that has
been adequately catered for
and i'm not sure whether that's relevant
for reserve matter or not but it is of a
concern
when you have this sort of system of 51
houses
there um we need to allow for any
extremity and i think there's been talk
in the
media recently about flooding i know
it's not in the floodplain and so on but
i just wondered if you might
be kind enough to comment on that please
thank you
um yes uh council passed i mean um
firstly to the uh the treatment of the
pumping station
um that has been considered by our
heritage officers
um specifically for the setting of the
listed building
uh is considered acceptable as set out
in the um so
that's our recommendation to you and in
terms of surface water drainage there's
been a
uh comprehensive drainage strategy
submitted with the
the application um we've been through
several revisions with the
lead local flood authority at the east
county council
and the current layout is considered
acceptable in accordance with the
information received so
again that's our recommendation to you
okay
thank you alex i've got any other
questions from members
counsellor field
[Music]
thank you just a question on page 23 you
report that the
uh from anglian water that the impact on
the public vowel sewage network has not
been adequately addressed at this stage
is there an update to that that is
missing from the pavement
um well obviously that's um that's an
issue which has been uh relevant since
uh
since outline stage as a point of
principle
now as i understand and please correct
me if i'm wrong
uh area planning manager but if
if there is uh inadequate provision then
um
the water authority have a a duty to um
ensure there is a suitable provision and
that will need to be
done at the appropriate planning stage
before
the development is is brought online is
that correct
yes it's one of those situations where
um
the principle of development in terms of
the capacity of the area
it would be a matter dealt with at the
outline stage
again keep repeating myself but
ultimately what's before us is the
appearance of the buildings
the landscaping the scale of the
buildings it is not
the connections in terms of that matter
your microphone temp um point of
information i think it
does say it's now being addressed at the
middle of page 47 where it talks about
foul water i know it's not what we're
here to discuss but just to
reassure people okay thank you for that
i would
suggest that uh such things should be in
the summary to our papers as well
councillor mellon uh thank you chair a
couple of questions
um on the surveillance of the open space
um can you um just tell me what is the
uh boundary treatment um
on the edge of the open space between
that and and the houses
to the to the north of it
oh yeah
right so um yes the boundary treatment
here they are proposing um
a hedgerow um now
we'll probably have to ask the applicant
at what height that is
uh it's going to be maintained at
because it's it's not clear from the
landscaping plan i have so yeah okay so
my supplementary question to that is um
is that hedge
hedgerow going to prevent the
surveillance that we've now obtained by
putting extra windows into the
into the the sides of those houses
and what's to stop the homeowners there
putting up a fence on the edge of their
property
which would also sort of countermander
surveillance
well um permitted development rights are
for boundary treatments up to
two meters i believe um so there
there would be provision uh for that i
understand
and um yes i just need to
uh to check the height of that with the
applicant to see what
what height that would be maintained at
but there may be a little bit of um
impact in terms of ground floor windows
but
i wouldn't suggest first floor windows
would be obscured by that boundary
we could just go to john do you want to
come in yes in terms of the outline
planning permission
uh no enlargement improvement insertion
of new windows or other alteration of
dwelling houses shall be carried out
that didn't
cover the enclosure but as you have the
layout before you and the landscape
before you in terms of this reserve
matter
if you feel it is appropriate on that
basis
to continue to remove further permitted
development rights
perhaps specifically to those plots in
question
you can have that option in the debate
to discuss and put forward
i would also say that you also have the
ability because landscaping is before
you
to limit the height of a hedge so if you
feel that there was a particular height
you wish to have that maintained at um
that is something an option in the
debate you may wish to
discuss and continue with okay thank you
councilman yeah so one more question um
the um the house closest to uh north
close
um i think you said it moved slightly
and but i couldn't really read the
distances on the slide can you just tell
me how much
difference there is between the previous
layout that we saw on
june the 9th and the current layout in
terms of distance from the nearest
property
so in paragraph 3.4 of
my report i've measured that
approximately one meter further away
from the boundary that's the building
and the proposed parking meter
approximately five meters
away from that boundary that's important
thank you and while we're on that
subject alex
the the two plans showing landscaping
there one of them
shows quite a few trees on the boundary
but the actual landscaping plan shows
very few
so can we clarify which plan we're
working to
with this because it's suggested it's
been enhanced
but one plan shows an enhancement and
one plan doesn't
okay um yes i mean i would i would
always
in terms of landscaping um i would work
with the
landscaping plan um that we may have may
have had some late revisions
uh to that uh that landscaping planted
to
record with the uh the layout is that is
that correct
yes yeah those those have been received
in the last um in the last few days so
we may have had that um
amended would that be appropriate then
when the agent is speaking that we ask
for that clarification
i would suggest though yeah because
are there any other questions from
members i've got another couple that
wendy would you like to
that one uh yeah just reading
about the sustainability energy strategy
that hadn't been submitted
as part of a condition has that been
submitted now
so obviously it's quite important as we
have a climate emergency
to do the best we can yes we certainly
have the um the condition as far as i
understand
um we have a
discharge and conditions application in
at the moment which covers
pre-commencement
conditions as i understand so
yes if that's a pre-commencement
condition that will be addressed as
as part of that discharge of conditions
application
but if it is a condition on the outline
that will be
addressed at the relevant time but we
can't get to see it
um i don't have that information
available
can i pause a second i'm sorry can i
just quickly check
so if i remember from last time this was
not pre-commencement it was
i'm just going for the outline now bear
with me one moment please
uh slab level so the sustainability of
the development
so no development show comments above
slab level so in other words they can
build the foundations but they can't go
above
until a scheme of water energy resource
efficiency measures has been submitted
too
so in answer to your question no we
haven't got that yet but we
unfortunately can't require that until
they get to that point
obviously it'd be nice if they did it
earlier but that's up to them
okay that i'd say that seems a little
odd because then if the slab levels
point the rooves in the wrong direction
to help with that energy conservation
how can we amend it after the slabs are
already in i completely agree with you
and
this is why we don't use this condition
again we have changed our protocol to
change it to concurrent with reserve
matters in most cases unless there's an
exceptional reason but that is an
old-style condition but
we had this delay that when we grant
something three years ago four years ago
we had to deal with the repercussions of
that decision and learn and go forward
it is it is we now go through questions
from the members is it okay if
i get you to answer that in the relevant
section you you will get plenty of time
to answer
i have a couple of any other questions
from members i've got a couple of other
ones
uh myself and councillor mellon said we
we've been around the periphery of the
site recently because we've been having
major flooding
uh on the edge of the site where the
railway bridge is it constantly floods
uh so we we went to check with local
landowners the water courses
and actually the turkey hill watercourse
is is a joy to behold
it's a very old-fashioned series of
ponds and ditches which are beautifully
kept
but recently they've had water lapping
up at the edge of their
listed building because of the recent
flooding events
that's not the issue that we then saw on
the site visit what we have seen all the
pictures you've got of the actual field
shows it as a recently cultivated field
well since the planning the outline
planning commission basically no works
have been done on site
this is now an absolute wildlife haven
and because of the proximity of all the
watercourses and all the ponds
frankly there are great christian
mutants everywhere around the periphery
of that field
now in the original ecology report
it says there were none on site well of
course there weren't because it was a
cultivated field
but it isn't that now uh and i've got
i've got pictures of
locals that are saying what's this
andrew and i said it's great crested
knee where did you find it
and it's on the periphery of this site
because it's now
a wildlife site so can i ask the
officers alex or john to confirm
the original ecology report is that
still in date and relevant
given that when the planning application
was sought in 2018
this was an arable field and now we're
at reserve matas it's actually a
wildlife haven
with a species in there that was not
found there three years ago
ecology reports tend to have a shelf
life of 12 to
12 months to two years um i don't know
what that is in this case
i would have to come back to you with
the answer to that
um alex do you have any information on
any updated ecology
since the outline um
[Music]
well yes i'm just looking at the um
comments of
our ecological consultants and in as
part of the current application
raising no no objection um i believe
there has been a
uh construction ecological management
plan
submitted as far as part of discharge of
conditions
i believe that's all been assessed by
our ecologists and i believe that has
actually been discharged
um yes yes so
um so i think our ecologists have looked
at this quite recently and
um yeah raising no significant
objections that's that's as far as i i
know i'm afraid that's my point that
they're responding to the original
report
but actually what's on the ground has
now fundamentally changed it was not a
good habitat for great crested mutes
three years ago
it is now a perfect habitat for them and
they are there
so i i'm just because obviously
ecologicals haven't been out on site
and all i'm saying is is the original
ecology report which everyone is
responding to and quite rightly
is that still in day and relevant is the
question
okay they figured me i'm just quickly
going through the kind of timeline
um so the original apology report was
february
uh 2018 uh provided an outline
stage which is correct now if i go over
to the
outline application again
bear with me
oh
so we have the condition 22 which is for
the ecology mitigation enhancement
measures
so all measures that are listed within
the
ecology report 2018 would be
coming forward as part of the
application
um there's no
requirement for a further survey of the
site
prior to those mitigation measures
taking place
um there is a landscaping ecology
management plan to come forward and you
just said that's been discharged
as well so that's only recently dealt
with and i would have
hoped that that would obviously be up to
date because it would need to be to be
discharged
um so that's only been done recently
that's pretty up-to-date as we can be
ultimately notwithstanding
the provisions of your planning
conditions we still have the
uh habitats directive and wildlife act
and the duty
on the landowner if they you know it's
like having und
unexpected contamination if you have
unexpected wildlife considerations on
site
this is still a criminal offence in that
context so the
we can do as much as we can do to
fulfill our duty but ultimately there is
still a duty falling on the land owner
and developer in terms of their if they
actually roll up and uh start digging
around
that that's the division there okay
i'm not quite sure if i got the answer
in terms of whether the
whether the original yeah what time
scale that was
so we we got it in 2018. 18 it would
have it would probably
be regarded as out of date after two
years at one point
so so that that was technically out of
date a year ago
uh and and this happens actually quite
often it's not it's not just
this particular field a lot of people
get planning mission and they leave the
land alone
um and in this case because of the
proximity of all the other you know tiny
ponds it is
now perfect habitat as demonstrated by
them being
you know on the boundaries of this site
on all three corners
i take the point away because ultimately
we do have the option to reduce the time
for applications to be implemented and
one of the reasons to do that
could be on the basis of the eco
ecological concern
or that the survey essentially only
covers a two-year period so rather they
give planning permission for three years
the option is for members and officers
to reduce that down to maybe
the two-year time frame um ultimately
the other option is to
impose a further survey requirement but
that further survey requirement
was not imposed on this particular
outline and that is the position we are
in
in this context yeah i i yeah thank you
for the answer i i
totally counsel passed me yeah i just
wonder if i can make a suggestion i
don't know whether it's possible
but if we were to give permission can we
put conditions on that because you've
clearly got all sorts of acts covering
wildlife ecology as well as planning and
which one has precedence but the common
sense approaches i would
suggest if we do decide to give
permission can we
can we put a condition to deal with that
appropriately please
get cautious um now
so obviously what i keep saying is the
normal things which is reserved matters
are appearance scale and
layout but of course actually there is
one exception the one exception
is because of the provisions of the duty
on the council for all council decisions
to
bear in mind the wildlife and ecology
issues
we do have the exception that we can
impose
in on that justification a a condition
on that basis and i would be more than
happy to
add a condition for a further survey
prior to commencement of works
that's is that helpful to members i just
have one other question
and that's on the overlooking
issue overlooking the public open space
here
which is the the largest part i think
we're talking about
uh has that been looked out by the
designing out crime officer
and do the insertion of the garages
there
block the views that we're trying to put
back in
in terms of the design our crime officer
they have been consulted at every stage
every
revision we've had in um
[Music]
we have not received um comment from
them at any stage so
we have attempted to consult them but we
unfortunately have not
received a response in terms of the
the garages could we have the garage
plans up again
um so in terms of
uh garages we're talking about
this this structure here yep okay
so see if we can find the elevations
so we have um single story uh garages
and um plot 31 i believe is is this one
um so uh it's uh
a single story scale where it's where
it's set
so i think from ground floor windows
there may be a bit of interruption
looking this way i would suggest but uh
perhaps not
straight ahead
as it's not right in front of those
windows okay
that's helpful so just to finish that
point so
we haven't had a response from the
officer concerned
so in terms of determination this is
down to our officers
and the committee then to make that
determination
because we haven't had the advice from
the officer
ian is that correct
right we now move on to public speakers
and the first of the public speakers
david chambers
from backton parish council i will be
giving you
the uh three minutes i think this time
for doesn't it three minutes
we we will be relaxed about that if you
need to finish up after the three
minutes and that will be extended to the
agents as well
thank you david chambers
thank you chairman um and good morning
members
when i last spoke to this committee on
this proposed development
i emphasized it was at variance with the
layout shown in the outline application
which
bacton parish council had supported
members will have seen our detailed
objection
dated may 2021 your decision to defer
for design review as the proposed
development represented poor design and
layout
allowed the applicants the opportunity
to rethink their proposal in a
meaningful way
we even hoped they might discuss their
revised proposals of the parish council
as they had not done so before drafting
their earlier application
but they did not i think we all
understand what's meant by design review
especially when related to poor design
and layout
the rise application only shows very
minor changes
and failed to address our concerns and
those expressed in the 16
detailed public comments
uh unanimously objecting to the design
presented in june those objections
remain valid
today along with further updates from
our residents
including those responses and a
comprehensive analysis the latest
application
which members will have received
directly from one of our residents mrs
liz
baton an experienced plan which i trust
you've had an opportunity to consider
it's worth reminding the committee that
the parish council was impressed by the
area of recreational open space proposed
adjacent
to saint mary's playing field in the
outline application
this area is still reduced by over 50
percent compared to the original as you
will have seen
in the presentation the over affordable
housing is still clustered together
and why on earth is the block to the
south of the site with its large parking
area still so
close to the properties on north close
when its repositioning could do so much
to avoid its harmful impact
on the residential immunity of the local
existing households
a meter isn't much of a change the
landscape buffer to the reorientated
parking
is a nominal offering and does not
overcome the proximity of the building
itself
we raise the question of trunks
construction traffic its conflict with
existing
vehicle movements and the need to avoid
peak school
traffic and arrival departure times here
and in hawley
in a construction construction
management plan that obligation
needs to be confirmed which highlights
the issue of turkey hall lane itself
the report dismisses any concerns about
the roadworks
saying these are addressed in the
outlying consent but this is a real
concern to the village and the reality
is the design associated with its
application
that application cannot be achieved
given the physical constraints of that
stretch of highway
i hope members will recognize that any
fudging on this issue
could result in a long-term road safety
problem from the additional residential
traffic movements on that road
which is already stressed by being the
high vehicle route to bypass
the low railway bridge in the village
and the question must be asked without
compliance with the outline consent
can this development take place at all
the parish council urges the committee
to refuse this application
thank you cancer chambers that was
almost spot on time uh
do we have any questions from the
members of mr chambers
council field just a brief one
you you talk about there being no um
consultation at all by the developers
with the community
but you also say
something on page 39 about papers that's
your um
council response that the new improved
recreation area included in the proposed
development was warmly received by
residents at the exhibition so
presumably it was some consultation but
it was rather early is that the point
it was an exhibition
i don't recall such gap i i think i can
help
cancer there was an exhibition ahead of
the original
outline which you on page 42
it show the layout on on the left
and that was i believe warmly accepted
because of its proximity to the existing
its size and it's it approximately to
the existing player it's america's chair
i was speaking about the consultation
ahead of the
application you heard in june
so i think that helps clarify that it
was about the consultation on
the reserve matters application here
okay
and of course that's ahead of its
committee uh
deferral and and the changes between now
and then
are there any other questions for mr
chambers
from other members um i just have one
question
coming from uh director the officers
coming out of that is
when given that bacton has a major
amount of development in it some
somewhere
circa 400 homes approved in this village
now with
a low bridge on one side and hawley on
the other
uh the only access into the village for
hgvs if you don't want to
go under a low bridge or come through
the middle of hawley
is to use turkey hall lane that's the
that's the
lorry route in and out of this village
is there a construction management plan
that roots
traffic to deliver this site without
creating the chaos that that we we do
see on a daily basis
the answer is the answer is yes number
13
is a construction management plan
contained within the outline consent
um i don't have access to anything
though further than that
i take it that's still outstanding or
has it been submitted
uh it's still outstanding thank you
so is that something that the committee
could
have imported procedure would be that it
would be a delegated matter for the
officers to deal with when submitted as
a discharge
condition
this is where pretend i'm not the chair
for a second and i'm the county council
this is the frustration is the early
outline permission
the county council officer response
was that no traffic from this
development would be turning north
out of this development when all those
that live in that area
know that that won't be the case and
that
traffic entering this site should only
really be entering using turkey hall
lane
and it should only be doing it coming
from the north because if it tries to
enter clay lane which
connects to circle lane from the south
they cloud the railway bridge
which results in the engineers coming
out and shutting the london norwich line
that happens almost every month at the
moment and what we're trying to avoid is
that happening again
because the cost to the lorry drivers
companies are phenomenal
so if we're going when we deliver this
site we want to deliver it sustainably
that's for everybody and also the
operator of that site not incurring
those thirty five thousand pound fines
per hour
um your condition in respect to the
outline includes means of access
traffic routes and parking and
maneuvering areas for the construction
and visitor traffic
um obviously that's not been put forward
to me where those traffic meetings
will be so we can't make that decision
at this stage
and and we won't have the ability to do
that is what you're telling me
the normal procedure at this stage it
would be a delegated arrangement
um i would have to take that away and
look at that further if
there was a request for it to come to
committee
obviously members have the ability to
call in applications
i think it stretches to discharge
conditions but i'm not sure
i would have to ask for the delegated
arrangement to be checked on that basis
thank you that's helpful okay we now
come to the
applicant an agent to speak jake lambert
and pete
blington um i'll give you three minutes
but i'll be
uh sorry did you have a question
uh cancer chambers with you sorry
right i'll give you the three minutes
and uh
great thank you chair um morning
everyone um
on behalf of our client flagship housing
group i'd like to thank members for the
opportunity to speak today
the report provided by your officer as
well as today's presentation are very
comprehensive but i'd like to say a few
points about the application which
if permitted will secure the delivery of
much needed housing
including policy policy compliant
affordable housing on a committed
development site
following deferral of the planning
application from development committee
on 9th of june
flagship housing group have carefully
refined the proposed development to
address concerns raised by members
resulting in improvements to the scheme
azure officers highlighted
natural surveillance of the eastern open
space area has been enhanced
with additional windows in plots 30 and
31 providing more direct overlooking
from active rooms within these cloths
like the kitchens and living rooms
in accordance with secured by design
principles this
combined with natural surveillance from
six more plots adjacent to the eastern
open space area
will provide sufficient natural
surveillance for people having a kick
about
and walking dogs on this field moreover
an additional window has been added to
the study within plot 3
to offer more natural surveillance over
the southern open space area
the relationship between existing
development on north close and proposed
apartment block
and parking court to the south of the
site has also been refined with
increased separation
and a denser planting buffer as your
officer has outlined earlier
these amendments are considered to be
considered to deliver acceptable
distances for side-by-side elevations
and will not negatively impact the
immunity of the existing residents
the amended scheme has received no
objections from technical statutory
consultees
including the highways and flood
authorities as mr patron g has already
mentioned
it's acknowledged that concerns remain
regarding turkey hall lane
and flagship housing group are
determined to work with the local
community
and elected representatives to deliver a
suitable and safe solution
at turkey hall lane in conclusion
flagship have sought to address the
concerns raised by members
and believe that the changes result in a
better development
the proposal represents a high quality
sustainable solution to bring forward a
committed development site
in the emerging local plan we therefore
respectfully request that council has
approved its application
in accordance with officers
recommendations
and should you have any queries myself
and peter will be
happy to have you to take them thank you
thank you that's under time
um do we want to go to um
do you want to say any more because you
still got some more time or shall i go
to questions from members
publishers questions thank you do we
have any questions from the members
councilor mellon
thank you chair um the um
strategic housing team manager has made
a comment in the papers that
um the affordable homes are in a cluster
in the southern half of the site
and it's not an approach that the
council supports
although the um or the registered
provider has agreed it
i wonder if you had considered um what
is
preferable to the council which is sort
of pepper potting those
around the site rather than having them
in one cluster
yes um we have considered this this
point um it is something we've reviewed
however the um
restrictions are imposed by the section
106 of 50
of the affordable dwellings needing to
be delivered
by by the time 50 of the open market
sell
dwellings are delivered has
significantly uh restricted the way we
can actually manage and deliver this
scheme
therefore what we have looked to do is
move two of the units away from that
to then break it up a little bit but we
have adopted
the approach that this is a tenure blind
scheme
um to try and mitigate that factor and
build out the phase in accordance with
the section 106
restrictions
canceller field
one of the objections i believe was that
the apartment
block was rather close to existing
dwellings
you have sort of addressed that but one
meter seems an incredibly small
movement could you explain
in any way what the reason for that is
yeah thank you so um yeah the apartment
block has been moved further north
uh and the parking court as well has
been moved
further north just to increase that
separation between that
the existing property um they're side by
side elevations
we feel the distances that we're
proposing are acceptable in that regard
um so it may not be abundantly clear
from the elevations but the apartment
block
the closest element of that to that the
existing property on north close is
single story
so beyond that so it's
yeah as i say it's the single story
element that's closer and beyond that
it's the um it's the uh the two-story
element so
it's considered acceptable by um by us
as applicants and
and officers as well
thank you and any other questions from
the members
uh cancer center uh yeah on the the
indicative the outline the um amount of
greens or the free space
seems to be sort of greatly reduced do
you have an exact figure about how much
has been lost through the redesign
because it's now a smaller patch and
then you've got the little bits of green
space at the front because you've moved
the whole development
further back i haven't got the exact
figures
between in front of me between the
outline and the reserve matters
um but the kind of approach that
flagship we're looking to
go for with the reserve matters um
layout
is to kind of redistribute open space
within the site so we still have the
eastern open space area we have a
slightly
another one to the south of the site and
another kind of smaller village green
type area to the to the um to the north
west of the site so
effectively looking to to almost yeah as
i say
is it's a it's a similar kind of a total
should we say
flagship of through through kind of
detailed design um felt that
and as i say we did um kind of present
in front of parish councils
prior to submission the application
and um again it was it was determined
that
the kind of distribution open space that
we're proposing is um
is acceptable and um
may i just come on your earlier point
about sustainability as well
um yeah so um so there's a
joint this payment is already touched on
there's a um
there is a package of pre-commencement
conditions uh separate planning
application from this one
in at the moment as part of that as the
sustainability and energy energy
strategy
that has submitted um i believe
condition 19
uh if memory serves me correctly um and
that sets out
all the measures that um flagship are
looking to incorporate
within the site and correctly from wrong
peter but we're looking at
airsoft heat pumps and everything above
kind of
part l building regulations requirements
and
that strategy has been reviewed and
endorsed by the environmental health
officer as well so hopefully that
answers your
point
sorry
is that one yeah um i've come sort of
come across it before that we sort of
getting promised like
solar panels and air source heat pumps
and when it comes to it there might be
three
that are in a development of a hundred
or whatever so again
you know are there any details on how
many houses are going to be fitted with
that is it going to be all of them or
is it just a small percentage is there
going to be any solar panels or
water harvesting facilities anything
like that within the development
so i can't recall the detail the exact
detail on my head but as i say
it's all on it's all publicly available
um on that planning application the
details of the of the strategy
um and as i say um it's it's it's it's
there
should you wish to kind of comment on um
it's not been
discharged yet um so as i say it's been
it's kind of been endorsed by the um the
council's environmental health
officer but um by all means please
review it and um
any comments you have we'll be happy to
take a further look
john yeah assembly can i just offer my
apologies i was
not aware that that condition was
already in and i said earlier that it
wasn't so i do apologize for that
misinformation
so that so that's in but not in the
bundle here and
not available for us to see today
it is a separate application and going
back to our earlier discussion
um it is at the moment likely to be a
delegated decision
unless there's changes into that process
that might be a discussion
outside of this meeting okay
right uh we now hear from the oh sorry
john peyton
john field
yeah i couldn't possibly agree there too
many johnson there you go
um just a quick question do we actually
have the elevations of that apartment
block the one to the south in our papers
so we seem to have everything or a large
collection but i can't find that one
um yeah i don't believe i've included
that there would be a lot of plans to
put into the presentation
um those plans are publicly available on
the file on
on the website um i don't know if we
have access to those
can we um possibly find them and come
back to you and put on screen
it would be good because that does seem
to be the controversial building and
that's the one that's missing
well shall we hear from the ward member
and that will allow you a
few minutes to to find that elevation
thank you john
councillor mellon
thank you chair um i just want to um
take a little bit of time just to set up
the background to this application
um and just to hopefully clarify to
members that um
the sequence of events um i'd just like
to also just point out that um
we're not supposed to have a secondary
uh avenue of communication
open and when i inter when i interrupted
earlier
it was something that flashed up in the
corner of my screen so
i certainly don't have uh any any line
of communication open to anyone else
um so this uh this site
uh the outline application came in in
2018
um a time there was we didn't have a
five-year land supply
as as the council and at the time
the site promoter told the committee
excuse me told the committee that the
widening
of turkey hall lane to 5.5 metres could
be achieved
and the committee approved the
application on that basis
now we move forward to more recent times
and we have this application for reserve
matters
and we also have simultaneously the
discharge
of conditions application
[Music]
at the same time and some of those
conditions have been discharged
already the construction environmental
management plan
is already agreed the construction
management plan which shows the hall
roots
is in but is not yet approved and that
cmp does indicate that the developer
wants to use a hall route through
backton and through hawley after the
widening of turkey
hall lane rather than coming in from the
north
um now the question here in front of us
is is the design of and the layout
of this development and to me the main
point is that the open green space
should be
at the heart of the development and not
as it
is here which is at the back of four
properties
and at the side of two other properties
the
development has not been designed with
the green space
at the heart of it where it could be
realistically
overlooked from properties at the moment
we have
uh added windows which i'm not sure are
going to
provide adequate surveillance
it seems to me that the uh the applicant
has refined
his plans but not reviewed them
there's been some tinkering there's been
some moving around
of minor elements but not substantial
change which i think is what we were
looking for
so at this stage i would encourage
members
to refuse this application until
it is designed properly and better for
the community
thank you chad thank you councilman do
we have any questions for
councillor mellon case password um
thanks andrew i'm just wondering for
clarification if the um
design um that the andrew just mentioned
there
regarding having the green space in the
middle
is at a legitimate grounds for refusal
or not
with this application we have before us
sorry to put you on the spot but it's
important
do you want to go i'll have a stab from
the chair and you can tell me if i've
gotten you it wrong
i mean we have design as part of
our material considerations in our main
local plan
they are still extent as far as this
this determination of this is
is as we're looking at it
we can determine those using those
material considerations
and depending on how much weight we put
on each one
can then tip the balance in our own
uh judgment on this one way or another
or as we did last time
we felt uh i think we felt was there
enough to
have a sustainable refusal was there
enough information to approve
and we we thought there wasn't enough so
therefore we deferred
to try and make everyone get us that
information that would
tip that balance i hope does that help
okay um in terms
of the last committee that was a review
and you gave a specific criteria for
that review which was to look at the
parking area adjacent to the existing
properties
and what they've done here in this case
is revised that they've twisted the
location of the apartment building which
i've just found but i need to check i've
got the right one
um and to try to pull it away from the
residents
if you feel that that hasn't been done
sufficiently
and causes an amenity issue still that
may be something you wish to explore
you also asked for greater supervision
of the open space because you felt that
the interaction between open space
and those properties wasn't adequate and
obviously what they've done is put
additional windows
into the buildings which would allow in
office of opinion
people to stand look out quite as a
fairly open
space square it would be adequately
overlooked
if you were to stand at that point
whether that's sufficient
again is a matter of judgment and a
judgment you need to undertake
if there are other design issues
regarding the entirety of the proposal
before you in terms of the appearance
layout scale of the development
that is exactly what is before you and i
would be
uh help that will be helpful to me to
understand a little bit more detail
the degree of harm of particular
elements
that you feel should be picked up upon
in in terms of any refusal
you may wish to contemplate if i can
also go there is one other factor which
john can tell me off
if i'm incorrect that isn't a bearing on
the determination of the
reserve matters but actually
it causes a lot of questions when we
looked at this
last time at committee the original
outline application works to the highway
were we were told were implementable in
their original state
not being able to achieve that came in
literally days after that deferral
so that's caused the public and also
quite rightly those in the
those giving advice from the parish
council to then
make sure they're forensically look to
make sure that everything
that we can look at as as as conditions
of an outline that we should be looking
at because a major plank because the
original outline
cannot be implemented in its original
form
have i i've not overstepped the market
however
i'm not sure what the point is of that
in context of the reserve matters
application before us
i'm suggesting that the members
and the parish council are looking at
what conditions
are in the reserve matters more
forensically
because the original outline cannot be
implemented in full i think what i'm
trying to say in a roundabout way this
has been really helpful
if this reserve matters have been
withdrawn and we had a whole new
application
so we knew everything about what we were
dealing with we're not in that situation
but i think yeah that makes it difficult
for us to know
what we can look at as conditions on
this outline and what we can
you are not looking at the conditions on
the outline you are not looking at the
outline you are looking
at the reserve matters specifically to
this
application before this committee um
i you know you and i would say trying to
tie the various aspects of that together
would be
uh inappropriate unreasonable and
possibly even unlawful
to do so you should you need to look at
the appearance of these buildings
and say whether you like them or not you
need to look at the landscaping whether
you think it's sufficient or not
you need to look at the scale if it's
too high not
high enough you need to look at the um
the layout and whether it's appropriate
in all other respects
so that is what is before members and as
i said
if there are elements that you feel are
poor design
in terms of appearance scale layout
that's what we need to understand
before i would say we then need to move
forward to a
reasonable refusal based on that if
that's the way we're going
thank you uh thank you for that
clarification
um where i was
heading to probably to get the words in
the right order was that
the committee has asked about whether
conditions have been discharged as part
of that outline
that they might seek to further
condition today
uh if and that's where they've been
asking questions about whether that be
appropriate or not
and we have explored that that's where i
was heading with that i wasn't
suggesting we
changed the original outline we can't do
that what i'm suggesting is there are so
many questions about that outline now
that we are having to try and push it
areas of conditions that aren't part of
the reserve matters
and whether they've been determined or
not at the moment that that's
what i was exploring with you because
there seems to be some ambiguity and we
we need to get this really clear
as to about what we're now about to
debate are we allowed to look at those
conditions that haven't been discharged
yet
are we able to call them back for
another committee to look at
or are they delegated to the offices to
go forward with
or do we we just stick to those
parameters that you described
a minute ago john with respect the
conditions
are not the concern of this meeting
that's very helpful thank you so
uh with that we now go over to the the
members
for debate who who wants to uh who wants
to start in the debate
come on don't be shy councillor
richardson
thank you very much uh chair i'll um
just give a brief
um summary of my views on this um
so if i can summarize it as best i can
the committee obviously felt when this
last came up for consideration in june
that there it wasn't a sufficiently good
application
for reserve matters that there needed to
be improvements and i think i i
agree with um something that counselor
mellon mentioned which is that
though there have been some tweaks to
this application it's not really a
comprehensive
uh revision of what's been considered
but the um
point share i think you made about
whether or not this is sufficiently
tipped the balance
um to warrant approval is is
is something i'm sort of actively
reflecting on so in terms of the
specifics
i think the layout is better than what
was considered previously what was in
the indicative planner outline stage
um i think the landscaping at some of
the boundary
and the inclusion of open spaces where
it um whether the proposed development
meets
um the road is is better is an
improvement
um on the question of design i think the
inclusion of more windows
overlooking in a positive sense those
open spaces is also
um leans in favor of
of this new application or this this
revised application
in terms of design more generally i
would describe it as adequate
i don't think it's i'm not especially
enthusiastic about the design
um but i can't really justify adding too
much weight to that because it's
it in my mind doesn't really warrant
a reason for refusal um
i think although having said that i do
do accept the point that there's ought
to have been
more consultation with the uh parish
council before any of these
world before the first revised uh sorry
reserve matters application was
submitted
i think that's a complaint we get coming
to committee quite often and i think
it's one developers should note
um although the inclusion of bungalows
for example 10
out of 51 is is not bad it's pretty
reasonable i think
um i do sympathize with the highway
point i had
a similar situation one of my villages
um not that long ago
where the width of the road was a major
source of contention
but i do accept the advice that we've
been given that that's not something
we're considering now this is purely a
reserve matters application
so on the whole um my view is that
there's been movement in the right
direction not as much as i'd like
um but having said that i don't think
realistically that's strong enough
grounds for refusal
um so i don't know chair whether you'd
like me to propose a
a way forward at this stage but if if i
can do so
i would propose that we accept the
officer's recommendation
for approval but with the um inclusion
of the condition that councillor
pasmore mentioned earlier requiring a
new ecological survey
um as as part of this so that's where i
am currently but i'm
uh happy to listen to the debate further
but that would be my proposal
for now thank you council richard
councillor phil
thank you largely with
the councillor but not quite all the way
i do find the layout largely
acceptable and the movement of the open
space is their division
that seems to me a compromise as usual
but it does
leave still substantial open space and
it does distribute some of it
closer to the road and closer to the
listed
and i find that reasonable
as i do most of the actual appearance of
the
dwellings proposed and the layout
however i do find one of the critical
issues from the
previous planning meeting that rejected
this
seems to be that the position of the
apartment block at the south and
i find it difficult to believe that a
movement of that of just one meter
is is sufficient to to address the
issues that were expressed
and we all have problems i guess with uh
with
parking courts which obviously an
appointment block uh get a considerable
amount of
use whereas i suppose in most
other cases of uh individual dwellings
they just tend to be just ignored
so i find i'm still of the view that
uh further improvement could be gained
and i'm reluctant to to agree this
application at the moment
thank you just as we shouldn't introduce
anything new now but did we get the
elevation of the abdomen block put up
members did ask for that um
do we have the technology to be able to
show it to the wider membership
yeah just on that point so what we will
be able to do is show it to the room but
it
won't go out on the live stream i'm
perfectly happy with that that's the
decision makers that need to see it okay
if you give me two minutes chair i'll
just hook that up
does anyone else want to add to the
debate while we
wait for that image to be shown
counselor turner
uh yeah i'm i'm still a little concerned
that
we have an issue of the the affordable
home still being clustered
together and that hasn't really been
addressed and i think that's quite a big
factor in the from the parish council
and the other is the anti-social aspect
that
it might occur on the field i'm not sure
whether a couple of
windows in the top you know and top
floors are going to make a huge amount
of difference because most people aren't
spending most of the day
sorry um and andy's point about having
the
the the green space in the center would
make a lot more sense
i i live in a 60s development and we
have green spaces in the center so all
the houses are
naturally overlooking and have very
little
trouble so that that troubles me i'm
also troubled by the fact
that the energy sustainable strategy and
climate change report
i've not had access to and i'm not fast
enough to have a have a quick read
there now so you know we're having to
make a decision on
and we haven't got all the full facts in
front of me
um and obviously i would like to see
more
more of those um more passive design
elements
and i'm not sure whether they're there
or not because i haven't seen the report
so like john
i'd be hesitant to accept it
and maybe another deferral
thank you councillor turner um
i believe we now have the elevation of
the uh the block concerned
in front of us alex uh indeed chairman
yes um this
is the uh apartment block in question
and this
i believe would be the elevation facing
those neighbouring properties
so uh no fenestration and the single
story element
as the applicant's agent has pointed out
it would be the closest element to that
and the two-story
element set further back from that
boundary
if that's helpful to counsellor field
council
could i just ask that the block appears
to have a
a a route for cars in and out of
the uh the parking area which goes
through the building i don't see any
evidence of that on that drawing
so is it the correct drawing it is the
great drawing because it's on the far
left so just where the um single story
element is
it's literally just off the side of the
slide there there's a sort of a
gray piece with a white underneath if we
were to continue along a bit for some
reason this extract isn't showing that
uh that is effectively an open carport
you drive through
to get to the carport behind there you
go
okay so there is a further element of
that building that's not shown
um you then have another block yeah
that's unfortunately
the elevation's been split in two so um
you then have that further block beyond
so you've essentially to be honest with
you it doesn't look to me like
effectively
two-story houses uh put together with a
a cover between and that's essentially
you drive through that in order to get
through to the uh
parking bay could you just show that
alex on that plane you just had for the
layout oh that's the whole thing there
that's helpful
so the single story element is on the
far right
which is the nearest point to the
existing residence
the access through is through that
driveway
um standard whip for a car and goes
through to the
car park port at the side the car
parking area at the back
yeah just for clarity as a bit of
artistic license on my part i may have
put them a little bit closer than they
actually um are so that's that's not a
um
completely accurate elevation but it's
just so you can see the two
side by side
yeah okay
cancer richardson you wanted me thank
you chad
i wanted to ask a quick question i've
just glanced through the papers to try
and find it i don't think i can
do you happen to know when this
application was submitted
originally for the reserve matters
yes we can find that information out for
you just uh just a second
so it was valid on the third of february
2021
so that's the point we take as a start
right any other members want to be part
of the debate just to sum up i have
one movement of approval which isn't
second in it and no other
motions on the table counselor passport
thanks andrew yeah i'm um i'm going to
second um
council richard harry richardson's
motion here i do think though i want to
say it's
highly regressible there hasn't been far
better dialogue with the public
with the improved matters i do have
concerns about the layout taken to
count andrew melons too many andrews um
because i do but the problem here is i
think if that would be such a radical
redesign
you would then probably have to
completely refuse it and i'm not sure
there are sufficient grounds to do that
we also mentioned earlier in our
discussions today
about the boundary heights of hedges and
so on and i think the sensible condition
then removing your permitted development
rights i think was that concerning the
fencing if i remember correctly
that did come up very early in the
discussion i didn't write my notes down
accurately enough
but if those are concerns i think we
need to be
conditioning those to make sure if we do
move for approval i would like to add
that
as well and i'm sure the planning
officer or it's okay
is that condition acceptable to you john
um if i may just summarize what i've got
noted down in terms of potential
conditions discussed so far
um we obviously picked up on the further
survey for protected species
to be added to this and obviously a
scheme for any mitigation for anything
that may be found
in that respect you then very early on
talked about
a limit on the hedgerow height to be
maintained along the boundary of the
public open space
and also uh removal i've put it down as
a removal of permitted development
for all plots adjacent the southern i
think it's the southern open space
is that the most
eastern open space uh space
uh to remove rights for walls fences
gates and other enclosure
so is the proposer happy for that to be
part of the substantive motion
yet you are okay
sorry of course if we have this um
ecological survey that could
fundamentally change all sorts of things
i don't know the legalities of that
but having had that clearly there must
be implications if you find it for
protected species there we'll
we'll have to wait and see what happens
with that but that must have
implications i do think that's important
you can't allow
one development to have this and then
others not and so on so
if that's included which harry suggested
then i that might have quite
profound implications anyway so i'll
leave it at that chairman but as i'm so
happy to second it with those additional
conditions
thank you thank you does it now we have
a substantive motion does anyone want to
speak to that motion
from any of the other councillors we've
heard the views of cancer field and
cancer turner did you want to add
anything uh
uh captain melon yeah i'm not quite sure
how much i'm permitted
sorry i hate to interrupt but as we're
in debating
yeah speak during debate can i answer
your question
yes certainly well i'm just looking at
the
agreed construction environmental
management plan
which does say that great christian news
are
around that area okay but it then says
this scheme has been registered under
the natural england district level
license scheme which permits the killing
injury disturbance capture and transport
of great requested news
so i'm not sure how much further another
another um environmental assessment is
going to get one if they've already got
a license to move them or or do whatever
so could we just have some
clarity from the officers on that i was
aware that they had got the license and
i where they
there was an expert that can potentially
move them and of course what we're
saying here is
we don't have a guarantee that that
might happen we just have someone who
could
so i think a precautionary condition in
what we've described
and with the the possible outcome is if
there is any
in terms of prior just prior to start
digging into the ground essentially
then they have someone who can actually
implement input mitigation that may
require
removal and transfer to another site
the the point yeah
the point here i wouldn't go down this
path of this condition if i didn't
think the likelihood that there was an
outcome if if the
outcome was we'd have to redesign the
entire uh scheme
i would probably advise that we would
need to go away and
look at that before we come back uh to
you or indeed refuse it on that basis
but it is given the likelihood and given
what i already know
that there's someone on board we have a
less risk
option uh in order to impose that
condition
although i switched on
yeah if we've been generous to council
of mello unless the applicant's happy
with what mr payton jesus said did you
if with your permission if did he want
to say something
of course thank you yeah i i guess just
to just to add on to
mr pokemon g's point really um yeah it's
our understanding that um
yeah the applicant has um has kind of
gone through the relevant channels to
obtain
necessary license and um again i'm not
an ecologist i'm not going to try to
explain the process because
um uh yeah but um as i say i understand
that
the rather than you know process and
and everything is being followed by the
applicant and and
hopefully that's enough to to reassure
that um
the right steps are being taken
ultimately for your members the point
here is that you are demonstrating the
duty
to protect wildlife as far as your
planning ability allows
and you are seeking confidence and
reassurance and on that basis
i would be happy to accept that
condition uh going forward that was the
point
thank you sorry chairman
the other issue there was of course the
durability of the origin
the survey we talked about the two-year
gap but it's now
beyond two years and i don't know the
answer but um i just think we're all
rather concerned about that and
need it clarified so we don't make a
mistake
thank you uh right i will take a few
minutes myself to speak
now we've heard from the members and and
thank you uh
i i from my point of view it's
incredibly difficult being chair you
have
duties to everyone and to make sure that
on balance that you are you are looking
at
everything objectively and and
only looking at those material
considerations that do affect your
planning judgment
uh i have to say the difference between
the two
iterations of the reserve matters i
personally feel
have not gone far enough i think there
are elements of design in here
that are urban and not rural
the the fact that you're driving under
structures to get to car parking
uh is a throwback to a sort of urban
uh environment where you had muses and
stuff i think that's that's totally
inappropriate
in a rural location i also don't think
that the
uh the residential and meaning of those
existing uh
residents in in pendulum close north
close sorry
have been addressed sufficiently and i
also think that the
the overlooking issues of that public
space
have have not significantly changed
there has been some amendment
but i personally think that on balance
that's not been
enough so i personally feel that this
is this plan is on balance
unacceptable but anyway we will now
put the proposed and seconded motion
to the vote and chairman just to
so everyone watching including on
youtube knows that
um it's the fact this is in your county
ward isn't doesn't matter here today but
councilman mellon is the district award
member and in
accordance with our usual procedures
he's been invited to speak as he would
have been anyway
without his membership of this committee
but will not be voting so
that's how we proceed as normal isn't it
thank you so can i ask the officer to
conduct the vote please thank you champ
the vote is now available in modern.gov
and with the
wording as put in by the um area
planning manager
so i will now start the vote in progress
sorry mr
carmichael do we have a concern being
expressed over there it's very regular
if
what was the point
after listening and listening to the way
that um or members have spoke about this
today
and feeling about what um councilor
turner raised
about redesign would it be
a motion for a second deferral to allow
enablers to go back
to discuss this sorry
we've got a proposal on the table unless
the two councils withdraw
it which i don't think they're going to
i think we we need to vote on it
penciller richards thank you chair um
just in light of that i think it may be
prudent to withdraw the motion if the
um applicant is happy to for a deferral
i think that's the most sensible outcome
if if if you were would you
be prepared to make them make another
motion or show from the chair
if you've withdrawn have you withdrawn
your motion
okay okay
should i ask for a five-minute break of
course
i would like to have a quick word with
my legal officer and i would
then possibly need a vote a vocabulary
agent if i may
yeah of course given that well shall i
shall we adjourn for i think everyone's
probably do a comfort break about now
shall we adjourn until
11 30 is that okay 20 minutes enough for
people to
is that okay
yeah 20 minutes so we'll reconvene at 11
30
and can i ask members not to discuss the
application
while we're in adjournment thank you
10 seconds
thank you well welcome back to planning
committee
development control committee b we're
looking at
agenda item 7a we've just had withdrawal
of the
motion to approve and secondary motion
to approve
so basically we have no motion on the
table at the moment
are i think i'm from does anyone want to
move a motion i would just say um andrew
i'd like to move that we defer
defer this application as long as it is
legitimate to do so
yep i think do i have a secretary cancer
field you happy to second that
wow right so we have a motion back on
the table to defer the application
and that second did john
yes thank you i feel i should explain
during the break i had
a conversation with our legal officer uh
in respect of the
um i call it interruption but i do
apologize the
introduction from the applicant in
respect of their suggestion
and i have also discussed the suggestion
with the applicant directly as i'm
allowed to do
to understand the scope of
the suggestion if you like ultimately
we are happy as officers to look at
deferrable on the basis that we will
take away
the points from this meeting that have
been discussed
and look at the layout and appearance
and design
further and to consider wider issues at
the same time so it does it is a moment
to give us a
break to look at improving the scheme
further and
that is a legitimate thing you can do
and you have done so thank you
thank you so we have a does anyone want
to speak to that motion
no no i think it's cancer interested
thank you chair um
just very briefly i will be supporting
the motion but just
touching on i think something that
several councils mentioned
um which was the frustration of the lack
of engagement with the parish council
whether this deferral might present an
opportunity for the
agent and the applicant to do just that
because i think that will stand in good
stead if
when this comes back for further
consideration
thank you council right so i think i'll
ask the committee officer to know uh
do the vote please thank you chair and
just before we get to that point can i
just confirm
with mr patman g that the um
wording for deferral will be that the
application
be deferred for the following reasons
and looking at the points raised at the
meeting
and looking at the land the layout and
design
further is that acceptable to the
protestant sector and
just to check i think that in a nutshell
yes
okay we all content with that
cancer field i wondered if it would be
helpful to have something to say
particularly with regard to the uh
apartment block on the adjacent to
other dwellings i think that just about
captures everything
okay can we uh right i've just added
that in chair
so it might not read
oh dude that's not quite worked out let
me just
right i'll just redo this voucher
right apologies for the delay there
so the vote is now in progress members
and we'll be showing in the
modern.gather app
um in the light blue color
counselor stringer can i please take
your vote i'll be voting for the motion
thank you very much
thank you chair all votes have now been
received minus that of counselor mellon
as he is the ward member so cannot vote
under the mid-suffolk planning
charter rules so that is five votes
for and unanimous thank you thank you
right we will now
move on to item 7b
dc 2102 924 land river six bells
church road felsham will allow a few
minutes just for people to do uh
shuffling around chairs and stuff and i
thank you for coming today thank you
yeah thank you uh right item number 7b
dc 2102 924 land to the rear of six
bells
church road fashion uh
to give us the introduction to the
application thank you
oh i've got apologies
maybe i do need to move
it's the arrows up and down isn't that
good
just if anyone's watching this from home
we are just waiting to sort out the
presentation
unfortunately it's the glow in my head
that i always think is the problem man
we've got somewhere lovely
right i can start again thank you
so uh this is uh for the direction of
two houses uh this is a full application
uh land to the rear of the six bells uh
public house uh church road
felsium um it's i'll come back to that
minute we'll just
skip through this then so we are in
felsham
and uh we are in the middle of felsham
here the village
and this is just a kind of wider view um
we are fairly central uh to the village
uh you've got the green you can see to
the left
where there's a number of historic
houses uh that surround the main green
and then just around the corner we have
the six bells public house
and the rear beer garden at the moment
and as you come out of the village to
the right of the screen
you have more
recent developments on both sides
including the
the cul-de-sac that abuts this
development site
so hopefully a bit clearer aerial
photograph
so we have a mouse doesn't come up
so the six bells pub is building just
here
and the land in question is just here
and we have opposite the church as well
just over here
which can be seen from the driveway the
site location plan
the official red line plan now this
actually includes
um both the area for housing and allows
for some slight changes this is the
reason why the red line is bigger than
normal but it does allow for changes to
the public car park
the access goes through the current
well come on the access goes through
the public car park at the moment it's
an existing access that serves the
parking area to the rear
and of course this development will
continue into using that
there isn't there's no parking spaces
marked at this time
but effectively the the need for the
access here would take out two parking
spaces
so we've allowed the red line to be
expanded so we can condition
the replacement of those two spaces
the constraints of the area so just
sketched out here is
roughly the site we have it's not very
clear i do apologize but we have a
number of listed buildings including the
six bells
uh to the front uh we have obviously a
listed church
and we have other listed buildings
within a location
the whole site and majority of the area
here is in the conservation area
and we are totally within the settlement
boundary
of the village as well
this is the proposed play out there is a
long history of applications and
refusals
on this site and it's taken us a little
while to get to here
over many years members will hopefully
remember or some will remember the last
application which was for free houses
essentially where those two houses are
and while there was no issue on access
heritage and principle
well there was one issue on heritage in
terms of one of those three plots
but it was essentially refused on the
basis of
three houses being cramped and poor
design and quite car dominated as well
this proposal essentially a revised
proposal
for just two houses seeks to address
that position
and take that forward so the two houses
just the cross section there essentially
the view
you would expect to find as you come
through the driveway and approach the
development
and each dwelling oh we've got that
that's a landscaping plan
sorry and then we've got the detail
plans of the proposals
themselves each dwelling is almost 8.1
metres high
around about five metres to the eaves
and obviously these heights are
excluding the chimney
they are slightly taller than the height
of the three previously
refused which were around uh 7.9 meters
7.6 meters and 7.4 meters
so these are 8.1 meters
but they do match the eaves height of
the
formal proposal
the height in general is not considered
out of context with the adjacent estate
or the public house itself
and is about average for a new dwelling
but they are quite bespoke designs they
pick up on the
flint detailing of surrounding
architecture including
the pub itself and these photos
give you some context so this is looking
down towards the
village green just out of the shot to
the right
is the entrance to the here we go to the
public house and the entrance that they
would use to access the two houses
and that's the existing driveway that
serves the public house at the moment
and would effectively where the van and
the car is you would
essentially go through there into where
these new two houses would be
placed
this is the view looking uh west again
from that driveway i put the aerial
photograph back on because it is easier
to sort of look at the context of
the proposal in that context of the two
houses essentially sitting in this space
and you would go through here into that
space
and then we have the remaining
beer garden proposal we have the car
part that could be extended if they wish
to
um and this area here is a sort of a
spare piece of land a surplus land to
the side
okay
on this occasion no harm is identified
by
heritage team highways are recommended
conditions
but it is noted that the access remains
a point of concern
it is agreed that the access visibility
to the west
and that is i keep getting more mouse
that is this way
is short by three meters
to meet the standard guidance of suffolk
county council highways authority for
30 miles an hour road the county have
referenced this specifically in their
response
however they considered and this is
agreed by your planning officers
that with planning conditions imposed to
achieve 40 meters
in that direction it will be an
improvement on the current provision
available in that west direction also
material
is the existing flow of traffic as a
commercial
unrestricted public house with or
without public events taking place
in the gardens and there is no evident
record
of accidents or sufficient clear reason
to warrant a defendable refusal
this was also the access not cited as a
reason for refusal
in the recent development reviews by
members for the free houses
or other applications since before then
this is now proposed for two bespoke
dwellings
to use the existing access drive to
avoid any heritage of concern
these will alter the views into the site
from existing gardens that surround the
site
but given the distance citing it's not
considered they will have considerable
impact
on amenity to warrant refusal and
therefore the recommendation for you
today members
is one of approval thank you
thank you john uh do we have any
questions from members
to the officer councillor pass morpher
uh thanks andrew
john are you able to tell us roughly the
distance of where the actual houses are
themselves to the
to the pub and then the big one which i
presume they've got it
in and around the pub there somewhere um
if you give me a moment i will
yeah just a rough estimate yeah thank
you very much
so can you just put the um layer back on
on the screen for me please
so in respect of the nearest point i'd
say the garages are slightly further
forward
so from the garage roughly there if i
measure that distance
to the physical the main house the main
pub itself
uh that would be there
43ish meters but that's very rough
thank you uh council richardson thank
you chair would you mind just popping
that slide back up again actually i've
got a question on on that and then uh
sort of a request for clarification just
in terms of that slide but i was looking
um
previously when you had the the map up
um of the village it looked as though
there was
sort of a large or not large but a
degree of woodland within that space
um so just in terms of the landscaping
on that slide i wanted to query whether
that's
trees that are going to be retained or
whether those are going to be um
new newly planted
and then the other question was just
around the desert the design for the
building itself
um i think judging by what's in the
plans
looking at the south elevation it looks
as though i think you mentioned flint
being used is that covering the entire
facade of the building
right let's deal with the elevations
first because i can quickly drop up to
those
um
so flint detailing is part of the design
in one
uh plot two essentially the gable
frontage she's got the flint work
um as you can see it kind of projects
out on so the two sides of
the gable projection and the main
central point and
if i then look at the other it's
essentially the same slightly different
wider gable projection
but the flint work is on there but
on this one we also have the two side
elements
with flint but essentially it's on the
frontage
not all the way around uh the building
uh the agent
of the agency um maybe add more but
ultimately uh yeah they are exactly what
they are one of you there
in terms of landscaping i haven't got
the
tree survey plan on my slides i do
apologize for that
but essentially there will be
the removal of smaller trees
between the top two main trees as you're
coming in with the driveway
um and we we have that coming forward
and you're you're right if i go back to
the
aerial photograph
so it does look quite green but of
course those trees are quite big with
quite
significant span uh spans but you are
effectively going between
trees as much as you can hence why
you've got that weird bend
on the driveway um in order to
facilitate that
there will be some loss of trees in the
middle there um but i will
say not trying to plead my case here but
it's not been an
issue before or come forward in any
previous scheme
any other questions counselor turner
uh yeah just reading through place
services it's basically the same sort of
uh theme of the ecology and the trees
that are going to be lost
and they've said they they would like
further
information i'm just wondering whether
you had received an ecology
no so your recommendation is not to
grant a planning permission
your recommendations to delegate to
officers subject to
the ecology ecology again has not been a
reason for refusal on this site
but it we we recognize we've moved
forward since the various refusals
in the past and so because that's quite
an expensive exercise
it's looking to get the principle
essentially established here that that's
an acceptable way forward we can then
receive the information on ecology
and subject to that being acceptable we
can then issue the approval if that's
what members decide today
thank you council field
the uh i wonder in whose ownership is
the plot of land
immediately to the west that has been
involved in previous planning
applications
perhaps more importantly what's the work
required to
extend the visibility display in that
direction
because because i understood there was a
listed wall or something there i wanted
to understand that a bit better
so there was there is a wall um that
forms part of the cartilage
of the public house and no works of that
wall are proposed
the simple solution in terms of the
visibility display is to essentially cut
back
the vegetation that are around that
corner and all of that is
in the control of either highway land or
the applicant
and so that is the improvement there is
no obligation currently with the current
access
for visibility display to be maintained
in terms of ownership i believe the
applicant also the
the pub owned all of that land um if you
bear with me just one moment i'll just
double check the
the original plan that came in with the
blue line just to confirm
so it's just frozen i just rebooted it
again i just need to find the drawing
again
i can't confirm that at the moment i
believe the land is all part of the same
ownership but
i'm i'm glad to leave that there a
moment i'm getting a nod behind you
that's the case any other questions from
members
i i just have one myself uh
you mentioned in the presentation john
that these houses were
average uh in size and height
uh i've just looked at the national
average at the national average
house is 110 square meters in area
and is between six and seven meters high
can we just confirm
what square meterage and height these
houses are
i said average height in terms of size
these are large houses
there's no denying that i bear with me a
moment i had that
information
[Music]
is that not in my reports
again can you give me a moment i will
give you the measurements of the two
houses in terms of floor space as well
thank you that would be helpful does it
after that does any other members have
any other
anyone else will ask questions okay
we'll wait for that answer
sure if you do wish to go on to public
speaking then mr payment you can respond
afterwards would be happy to do that
yeah we did okay right we don't have a
representative from parish council we do
have an object to mr nicholas
pinali sorry chair we do have the um
representative from the parish council
hayley nunn we do
oh sorry sorry it's not on my list sorry
we do have haley no
sorry would you like to have three
minutes now
yeah of course of course take your time
that's fine
so i'm on am i yep the proposed
development is at the very core of our
village
and the article 4 conservation area this
area of the village has designated
heritage assets in the six bells saint
peter's church and the two neighbouring
properties
as well as some non-designated assets
most of which would overlook the
proposed development
the ordnance survey map of 1885 shows
the space jointly bounded with the six
bells and three ways house
little has changed here since the
publication of this map and many of the
views remain the same and should
be preserved lp 21 of the submitted new
joint local plan is clear
in demonstrating the important
contribution heritage assets make
including those non-designated to the
character and appearance of an area
this historic triangle reinforces a
sense of local identity
and this application with even taller
buildings does nothing to negate
our concerns your policy refers to 7 000
listed buildings and 60 conservation
areas
and its intention to preserve these is
clear felsham should not
be the exception lp 19 refers to the
importance of the relationship between
landscape and the historic environment
detailing that the character of the
landscape is influenced by its historic
divide
environment and that the landscape can
be important to the setting of a
historic asset
this is absolutely true of felsham six
bells and peter's church
lp 13 of your plan focuses on
safeguarding the economy
the hospitality industry has more than
ever needed outside space
the six bells has both historically and
re recently utilized the meadow for
functions
and this land is even more important now
removing this facility from the six
bells by building
will undoubtedly impose a negative
effect on its trade and ability to
maximize its potential
lp-13 also directly refers to protecting
the operation of existing businesses
and only approving where there is no
immunity conflict arising from the
development
in this case there is a direct conflict
because of the loss of the land but
also the sharing of construction access
with trade access
therefore once again this obligation
directly conflicts with your own
planning policy
your plan talks of delivering
appropriate housing in this case we do
not consider this housing appropriate
there is no identical need for large
housing
in felsham your joint local plan is
there for a reason
to form the basis for considering
applications your plan
focuses on sustaining economic growth
including sectors such as hospitality
which now more than ever need support
there is no
ambiguity in your local in your joint
local plan
its intentions are clear to enhance and
at the very least
sustain economies maintain or enhance
the well-being of communities
whilst preserving the heritage and the
environment
this application for land at the six
bells is in direct conflict with your
very own plan
and for this reason i implore you to
stand by your own documentation
and help felsham enhance our precious
historic assets our rural economy
and preserve the well-being of our
beloved community
well done do we have any questions
for the speaker councillor richardson
thank you chair just a quick question um
you referenced during
um your comments that there was sort of
a loss of immunity for the pub
uh i'm just looking through our um
report which gives sort of a summary of
the objections
um but don't go into the specifics so i
just wanted to clarify other
owners or the management of the pub
objecting to the scheme itself
to us yes in terms of what they say to
us yes they
use the land recently in june for a
family event
that's helpful thank you councillor
field
you were saying there's no demand for
large houses in
felsham always felt that there's a
demand usually for a range of house
sizes
appropriate to the local economy so on
what do you base that feeling
are there a large number of empty large
houses in that village
the large houses struggled to sell but
we actually carried out housing needs
survey
um and the results of that were very
clear and that there was a demand
for small small housing and
bungalows if if any but it was yeah
definitely not large five bedroom
properties
any other council of possible first
thing i'll come back to cancer which is
yep
um thanks andrew i was just um i do i
drive past um this place quite often
because my sister lives just around the
corner i put
cockfield that's going to do with it i'm
just wondering how
how successful is the pub how viable
i know it's been difficult obviously for
the last 18 months but before that it's
now
getting incredibly busy um and it's
becoming very popular
not only with felsham to be honest but
because of the closure of pubs at
cockfield hesset and bradford george all
our neighbouring villages
the demand for our pub if anything has
increased
i should have to make sure i frequent it
then sometime thank you councillor
richardson
thank you chair um i have a feeling the
answer to this is no but i just wanted
to double check does felsham have a
neighborhood neighborhood development
plan in place currently no
okay what's the housing needs thank you
do we have an answer to the question
about heights
so in terms of floor space plot one is
189
square meters and plot two is 176 square
meters
and the height they are both 8.1 meters
high
thank you thank you okay so that gives
us an idea of
compared to average that's fine that's
fine thank you
uh right where do we go to now we now
have
a representative
an objector nicholas pena you to speak
i'd give you three minutes and i'll be
generous
thank you three weeks ago i received a
number of undisclosed documents and
emails from my freedom of information
request to paper council back in
december 2020
and although the documents relate to the
previous application which was refused
at the planning committee on the 31st of
march
the documents are still relevant and
have a significant banner on this new
application
one of the documents was a heritage
report by the herit by the council's
heritage officer
raising a number of concerns that was
never disclosed and never made public or
submitted onto the planning portal
instead a very different heritage report
was submitted
with a large proportion of the
undisclosed report containing the
concerns not included in it
in order to make the new heritage report
more favorable
the second documents were are emails
between planning and highways regarding
the pubs access
visibility which i will come to later
these are some of the following concerns
from the missing report
the current application proposes to
re-route the access to the new dwellings
using the existing pub
access while this is no longer
the demolition of a section of the
curtivage wall i consider this to be
harmful in other ways
firstly it further and more notably
fragments local historically belonging
to the six bells
over the previous applications as the
new access would
more noticeably divide the immediate
curtailage of the six bells
this includes physically separating the
pub from its curtinage
and its outbuildings and walls i have
concerns that these features would no
longer read as an integral
part of the historic function of the pub
if they are severed by an access road
that does not just serve the pub
the fragmentation seems likely to have a
vis a physical
dimension as the submitted proposed plan
appears to show a physical
demarcation of the access road which i
consider would provide a further
physical sense of division
in my view this ability to appreciate
historic connection would be diluted by
the access road
i also have concerns that the new
proposed route
may now directly affect the viability of
the six bells pub
this appears to have been a pub for much
of its history
and as such it says it derives some of
its significance from the site
i also note that so highways comments
regarding visibility displays
i am concerned that the suitable
visibility space may not be achievable
without
materially and detrimentally affecting
the pub
including its outfit uh it's curtains
listed
boundary walls i also have concerns that
the eight
the height of mass of plot one appears
to have increased
over the previous application however
i have concerns that the potential
increased and height of plot one
could be such that it could now appear
overly dominant within certain parts of
the conservation area
particularly from upper green to the
west this area is characterized largely
by relatively small
historic cottages framing the green
including
on the east side a number of key views
identified in the felsham conservation
area appraisal of 2020 page 12
of 22 across the green this document
also identifies many of the buildings on
the east side of upper green as
important unlisted buildings
and which i thus consider non-designated
heritage assets
this proposed building could become an
overly prominent feature within this
area
rising above the historic buildings of
perry road distracted from an
appreciation of these
buildings and also further drawing
attention to its incongruous design
the height of the proposed houses in the
previous application was 7.9 meters
if i could ask you to wind up you're
well over your three minutes thank you
sorry the height of the proposed houses
in this application now
are even taller at nine meters
all of which these concerns which were
not made public to us
and in this current application there is
no heritage report
just a mere phrase letter to the
planning officer saying
i consider that the current proposals
would not result in any harm
mr payani i think i would have to ask
you to stop there thank you
that's okay thank you uh we now
we now go to uh we don't have a
supporter but we do have the
applicant jeremy heppel uh
oh sorry here questions to the uh to the
speaker anyone
nope john did you have a question about
the
nine meter claim um just to point out
the application is not for over nine
meters the both houses i i take the
exception that chimneys are slightly
higher
but the majority of the two houses
propose to you that the ridge line is
8.1 meters high
i can comment on those other comments if
necessary but i
will leave that at this moment time if
there is a formal complaint
in that that would have to be a separate
matter from the uh speaker
yeah okay uh can we now go to the
applicant then jeremy heppel you have
three minutes and
as with all the others i will be
generous with that
thank you good morning chair members and
thank you for inviting me to address you
i attended the online meeting when the
previous scheme for three houses was
refused
members concerns were over over
development
and car domination but no issues of
principle
or access it was suggested during that
debate
that the site was better suited to two
houses
having listened closely to memphis
concerns the revised scheme therefore
reduces the number of houses to two
and also emits the central circulation
area for cars
which was the cause of some debate
previously in doing so
both ground coverage and hard standing
areas are significantly reduced in the
new scheme
the revised proposals in our view fit in
well with the character and density of
the area
and our respect for the conservation air
and the list of public house
points which have been confirmed by your
heritage team
in regard to the height of the houses
they are five meters to the ease which
is
a standard distance governed by floor to
ceiling heights
and they have a standard roof pitch the
increase in height
overall has been mentioned is simply
because these houses are large
and therefore have a deeper floor plan
and that causes an increase in the ridge
height of the buildings
i trust overall that members are
supportive of the genuine efforts that
have been made
to respond to the concerns raised at the
previous meeting
highway safety was not a reason for
refusal of the previous application and
the highway authority has
not objected to the latest proposals as
you've heard
by reducing the number of dwellings to
two the new proposals will generate less
traffic than the previous
scheme your officer report makes it
clear that this is a well used existing
axis with a good safety record
and that there are no highway safety
grounds to refuse the application
provided that visibility displays are
maintained as per the
suggested condition at the previous
meeting members raised
a query about the safety of future
residents particularly children
walking to their houses through the pub
car park as a result the plans now
propose a dedicated pavement between the
road and the houses for residents to use
this represents a further highway
enhancement
in conclusion the applicant is content
that proposals are compliant with the
relevant local and national planning
policies and achieve sustainable
development
the proposals will also have a material
benefit to the viability of the six
bells
by virtue of the capital receipt for the
development site being invested back
into public house
and i can confirm that hawthorne leisure
the owners of the pub do support the
proposals i trust that councils will
follow the advice of their experts
and grant planning permission for this
scheme thank you for your time
thank you that's we had a few seconds
left well done
um do we have any questions from the
members uh council passed more than yeah
thanks
and you mentioned at the end there about
the money um
that would be um i suppose the for the
if
planned permission were granted there
would be obviously a substantial capital
receipt
and you said that would be invested back
into the pub i don't think we have any
we can't stipulate that in planning
anyway i don't think that's a material
consideration is that we can't tell
people
what they have to do with their money i
don't know whether our planning officer
could just comment on that
there has been circumstances where that
has been the subject of a 106 agreement
where the um for whatever reason
the sale or money is invested back into
and it is
sometimes pubs but that is not the
proposal on the table
in respect of this application that is
not deemed to be required
in this application given the extent of
pub garden available
given your policy position unfortunately
the retention of public house
policy didn't it wasn't saved um it was
so it's essentially now just guidance um
we don't have the position to do that
and we have not needed to have the
position to do that
because it's not become an issue with
all the various applications that have
been on this site
and the planning appeal many years ago
it is not
a material well it was not a material
issue that was given weight
to to pursue so it is not something that
we have proposed
if the committee were to decide that
could it put it down as a condition
i know you haven't got it here no i
would say you can't because i can't
identify the harm that it would mitigate
um
and i can't i at the moment i can't
identify a policy that i could base on
to require that i understand thank you
thank you very much welcome to
councillor richardson
clarification on the retention of pubs
policies it wasn't saved
wasn't uh
in respect to the supplementary planning
document was not a saved
document many years ago so we now treat
it as guidance
thank you for that clarification
councillor richardson you had a question
yeah um appreciate this is a relatively
uh minor point but on both the
site plan and the cross section you can
see that there are cart lodges
associated with with
both dwellings but looking down at the
further sort of detail
and so this is from the office's
presentation it doesn't seem to be um
given any more clarification about
dimensions and size and things like that
and i just wondered why that was and
secondly again
might be irrelevant but why cart lodges
were preferred over
garages given that the latter tend to be
more secure i don't know if that's a
material consideration but i was just
curious
shall i allow the applicant just to
answer i take it it's just a design
choice
it's just a design choice and in our
experience carports generally have less
of an impact in
constellation areas you can see through
them they're a lightweight structure so
you know we think they work better in
this context so it was a heritage-led
decision if you like
thank you uh councillor turner then
councillor field
uh yeah you talked about a dedicated
pavement
to access to the new houses where abouts
will that go
because the entrance to that site is
very narrow i did go and
have a look yesterday and it is on a
sharp bend
um and i think their children are going
to be living in those houses and
and adults as well um
could i asked the presentation to be put
on screen again please
and now i can um follow the path for you
if you if you bear with me
right i've got using narrower again hang
on
okay so um as you can see we've got a
paved
area that runs all the way down
and to that point there um i think bins
are stuck here at the moment in the font
but essentially a bin store would be put
back to there so that is the uh
that's the proposal shown how wide is
that going to be
and is it going to be raised the paved
area is only going to be about a meter
wide i will check if it's going to be
raised because i'm not sure unless the
applicant knows off hand
because presumably that's going to
reduce the entrance even further
it wouldn't be raised i would suspect
but it would be a different material
um but it wouldn't be raised it made
things difficult with
beer deliveries and stuff i'd imagine if
you raised it so
i can double check the detail but that's
how i'd say it at the moment thank you
thank you cancer field
two things perhaps there appears to be
some boundary treatment on the opposite
side of that road the one the close
to the pub but i my eyesight wasn't up
to seeing what it was on our
plans um so i wonder what that treatment
is
but the perhaps more important point is
there any assessment of the
impact on the financial viability of the
public housing
clearly when people buy large houses
adjacent to
buildings that generate certain amount
of noise from entertainment or whatever
there's often pressure for such noise
and entertainment to service
so is there any assessment of that
impact
are we going to answer john
so i thought it was still questions to
the applicant um
so in terms of the landscaping um
i where was i where to the outbuilding
can you put your microphone on oh sorry
between the uh
the driveway and the remaining uh beer
garden
yes so that's um a hedge row uh to be
put in there
um okay the help portal
could you put your microphone on john
oh sorry in terms of the economic um
assessment of our business the answer is
no we we haven't got that and we've not
sought to have it either
so if i'm councillor mellon
yes just another question for the
applicant um
the um the houses shown have got
chimneys on them
is that just a design feature or is that
are they going to be
um usable
i would say it's primarily done as a
design feature but i think if somebody
wants to have a wood-burning stove then
they would be usable chimneys
thank you uh just one of the just for
clarification really
so we have not sought or we have not got
any
input from the economic development team
about this
no because we have a history of refusals
where that issue has never come up
as a report of refusal so it would be
extremely difficult and unreasonable to
look at the entire viability of the site
when you have what two factors really
one it's never been a refusal issue so
materially i have the entire planning
history against me doing that
and at the same time this public garden
is a significant size and even with the
reduction
if you compare it to a lot of other
public houses around in general terms
you have got excessive amount of land
available still so
it is not seen as a reasonable point it
is also not a requirement of your
current policy
context we don't have that requirement
for that information
but we do have policies that that seek
to safeguard economic current economic
development
you have a policy in terms of retention
of the public house
its associated land arguably is part of
that
but again we've not ever sought that and
it's not come up as an
issue on the material planning history
of the site not at this site but no i i
was talking about general policy
i'm certainly sat in meetings where we
have
had debate and input as to whether
domesticating an area would affect the
viability
of a lawful business and and surely that
is a material consideration
it is a material consideration but your
policy i would argue
is exceedingly weak on that point until
and i know it was mentioned earlier
we do have an emerging joint local plan
which at the moment you give limited
weight to
but that has stronger policies in
respect of that issue
coming up but it this current policy
position uh the current local plan
you only have a guidance in terms of
retention of public houses
you have uh e6 which is um
the economic point of the local plan uh
which
but even e6 even though it says
retention of
when you look at the policy it says we
are happy to accept
any other use as long as it's not um
traffic or environmental impact
so it's a bit of a diluted policy
it is a material consideration in
general terms which you can have a
debate over
but it's not a strong policy point i
would suggest but that is
my opinion to you okay thank you that's
really helpful
the there's mentioned in the highways
response which obviously is an
interesting one here
about the given the improvements
it outweighs the fact it isn't policy
compliant
could you just point out what what is
classified
as an improvement
could you put the display back on for me
thank you
essentially the improvement is the
securing of the visibility splay
which effectively is represented by that
ignore
the uh bit at the bottom but essentially
you're looking at the securing of that
40 meter visibility display in one
direction 43
meters in the other direction and we
would then have a condition
that would maintain that land not to be
overgrown that gets captured by that
visibility display
that as far as i can see is the only
improvement and obviously
how do we condition that cars don't get
parked on it
um they would cause an obstruction
within the visibility display they'd be
over 0.6
so they would not be they'll be
essentially in breach of the condition
however i would also say probably the
highway code would have something to say
about that as well
right so so are
are there parking spaces at the front of
the public house
now that will be lost due to this
commission being granted
the front of the public well the front
is used for various things
um in fact on that aerial photograph
they had lots of tables and chairs out
there
if i was my way around they have tables
and chairs
i thought i had another one that went
round further sorry
um
as you can see well it's it's um it's
one of those positions where
the widening of that point of road has
historically evolved over time
it does allow cars to pass each other
better on that
stretch of road especially if you've got
a lorry coming the other way
but i would say parking on there
wouldn't perhaps be wise
but that's at the risk of the owner of
the car
in question okay thank you
cancerfield the diagram of the
visibility display had the
road width marked at five and a half
meters
but the uh side of that adjacent to the
pub
he appeared to be somewhat a figment of
imagination rather than physical
boundary will that be in any way marked
as part of the
generation of the visibility display
otherwise you're clearly measuring the
visibility display from a
position drivers are unlikely to adopt
the trouble here we're dealing with is
is currently rough land that is unmarked
um on the ground so you know taking you
what you've done is
what we've done here in this case and
this is what the highways authority have
accepted
is um taking a reasonable point of 2.4
metres back from what is reasonably
defined as the edge of the highway but
there's no markings on the edge of the
highway so you're
it's not very clear and ultimately
taking what they think is a reasonable
position that gives them
that degree of visibility um
it's not perfect um i will agree and i
think that is an argument that i know
neighbours have taken up with us
in terms of they can argue it a
different way because of where you stand
to take the initial measurement
ultimately the prevailing factor here is
that we have an existing access
for an unrestricted public house it does
have
events going on in terms of the village
a lot of people probably using the land
going back and forth and conflicting
with the
commercial use potentially but
ultimately that all goes on at the
discretion of the current owner that's a
private matter
but we we have to accept the worst case
scenario is possible that this pub could
be
really really busy two houses and the
outflow of the traffic for two houses
versus
an unrestricted commercial use we don't
feel is a reasonable difference
it could and also can i just have
clarify clarification that the
is all of the visibility display inside
the
red line of the application site
well the immediate answer is no because
the red line doesn't cover the front of
the public self
when obviously the direction of travel
of the visibility display goes off
in that direction it doesn't need to be
all within the
red line some of it is but on the basis
that we cover
partly highway land here as well and we
don't normally require that in a red
lion sense
okay thank you uh casa turner
uh yeah um
sorry when the houses are being built
presumably the lorries are gonna have to
access
the site through that entrance as well
um and presumably that's gonna impact on
the
on the the pub and the people using the
pub for a certain amount of time
um has that been considered
um i would imagine they would need to
make arrangements
um to secure you know safety obviously
of the
people using the publishers as as much
as the construction workers
the we do have a construction management
plan uh conditioned
to be agreed um for further details on
that point
so i'm also concerned about obviously
that access and those lorries get
through there up on that sharp bend as
well just
just doesn't seem very safe um this is
the point of health and safety and the
risk
obligated on the developer to undertake
planning can only do so much
and unfortunately builders have you know
we can imply all sorts of things but it
comes down to the individual builder
ultimately in their practices on site
there's obviously the heritage issue if
those lorries do bump into the wall
that's
listed and and the pub possibly because
it is a very narrow entrance
that is their risk and if they commit
criminal damage to a listed building we
can obviously take that up into
enforcement terms well
thank you i just want one other tiny bit
of clarification we've gone to the wall
member
it says in the highways response that
the condition
must provide a minimum width of four and
a half meters
from the nearby edge of the carriageway
it can be just
that that is achievable isn't it yes
thank you over to the board member
councillor
i'll give you three minutes and a bit
more
sorry just just to clarify the board
member has an unlimited amount of time
under the public speaking rules thank
you sorry i didn't hear that
you have an unlimited amount of time
sorry for my lack of experience okay
thank you
first of all i just want to make a
statement about
a media coverage
that said that there had been no
requests for a site visit
um for this application
[Music]
from this to this council and we wish to
dispute that even the local mp joe
churchill
had asked for a site visit and for those
members of this committee
that here now i make no apologies for
calling this
site in again because as you can
see it is incredibly
controversial i have quoted policies hb
1 hb 13 hb 2
on design and residential amenity
the application now has dwellings and i
believe far in excess of the height
of the neighbouring cottages and houses
the size and scale
are completely out of proportion
alongside
the site of these small flint and
rendered cottages
and the six bells itself all of which
are included in the conservation
area current policy states
applications should be sympathetic to
local character and history
i question why on the previous
application
as has been discovered from mr panya
through his um application for
further uh correspondence
the heritage officer stated that
proposed works
would have the potential to conflict
with the pub
which is a grade two listed building so
surely any development here would have a
significant
impact on that alone and with the use
and viability of the pub
he also in that email asked for advice
from the economic development department
of this council and yet we have had
nothing
despite the council commitment to
supporting local businesses
and i quote lp 29
any loss of services and facilities
will be resisted on the actual planning
of the application
and the proposal before you have
five bedroom house that surely
could easily have three cars there is a
proposal
for a walkway safety of children but
that's
also must be for the safety of people
with disabilities
and i would like to point out that that
goes alongside
the um listed wall but also
contains out buildings that belong to
the pub
which obviously have got doors on them
and at the moment the car parking for
the pub is obviously being used with
external seating
due to covered regulations and therefore
the
whole of that car park areas had to be
significantly reduced
i would also like to question um
on the photograph you showed there of
the
entrance to
rubbish bins and there is some comments
from
um fire and safety
about access through that site but we've
had nothing from
um waste on how the
bin lorries are going to be able to
negotiate in and out to those large
dwellings once again i and the community
continue to be at odds with the
recommendations on
highways despite trying to prove there
is no risk to car
users and pedestrians i have been told
that even someone on horseback needs to
pull out
onto church road in order to see round
that bend
at upper green and this has also been
shown by the users of mobility
vehicles that it is impossible to
negotiate
safely and your policies should address
the needs of people with disabilities
we've been told there is no record of
accidents but this is untrue
i have also quoted policy t10 history of
flooding the planning office has said
there is no record of this but i can
assure him
that there have been numerous
inspections by officers
at that corner and a problem has been
identified
causing vehicles to pull out onto the
other side of the road
particularly when the water freezes
the successful community shop on church
road is delivering
vehicles parking therefore forcing
driving
from lower green to pull out into the
middle of the road
facing any from the opposite direction
the school bus parks there with
potential danger to children crossing
from meadow close
as there is no footpath on that side
from the pub
you have been shown and told of the
drastic loss loss of the open community
space
this is something this council has vowed
to protect
once again there are still numerous
conditions
still to be agreed including from the
ecologist
who is still has a holding objection
due to insufficient information
particularly on
bats there is no indication of any
potential loss of trees
and what conditions will be imposed on
construction vehicles
using this limited site also on
archaeology this still needs to be
done as i say chairman i make no
apologies for
calling this application again
it is obvious from all of the number of
refused applications
that this site is totally unsuitable for
any development it is clear that the
developers are trying
any computation to squeeze in some
completely unsuitable permission onto
what is a
site with far too many constraints
so i urge the committee to refuse this
application
thank you chairman councillor
good question thank you andrew um
it's just clearly a pretty controversial
site and as i say i said earlier i do
more or less know the air i don't know
the site specifically and i do agree
with you the water sticking on that
corner i've been around there many times
and
there is a big issue there i just wonder
would the board member agree penny
um because it's such a sense of sight
would there be merit in arranging a site
visit here
i mean is he come up i think somebody
mentioned it earlier
i mean if you wish
and that's down to the committee but yes
i mean you know
it's always better to look yeah
are there any other questions to the
ward member
no right oh sorry john
can i pick up a number of points that
has come out of that uh
well a number of things really um first
of all in terms of
site visit uh requests can i confirm
with the governance officer there's been
no site visit requests for this
application
that you're aware of none that have been
requested at this committee or sent to
committee services thank you
i understand there were site visit
requests and possibly
there's variations in terms of previous
applications but i'm not been made aware
of any for this application
in terms of other details um both
the board member and the neighbor pulled
out details of the previous application
and the previous response of the
heritage officer
to that application for free houses
now i wasn't going to do this but i
think i need to go over this publicly to
state it for the record
because ultimately there is a big
difference and i don't want
members to get unlawfully sidetracked
in terms of the heritage officer they
did provide me with an initial
view which is what's gone public that is
not the public view or the official view
that was actually then submitted later
so the freedom information request
is valid fair enough anything that gets
put between officers as an internal
discussion
is fair game but ultimately the
concluded view is the one that was made
public in respect of that application
the heritage officer did touch upon
access issues
viability issues all of which are
outside of their remit
it is not for them to comment on those
points their point is to comment on
heritage
and that was one of the decisions that
we made when i went back to the heritage
officer at that time
to ask him to clarify heritage not
other matters they then went
through also the planning history of the
site and concluded their view
given the appeal history of the site and
the appeal
considerations of the heritage matters
so in the end i would say to members if
they are looking back at the past and
they are looking at the free application
of free houses
to consider only the public consultation
response
and that is the official response from
the heritage team
now that response did have an issue with
plot one
which was one of the three plots it did
have an issue with the height
of that particular building this
building this scheme is a different
scheme it's for two
they are more centrally located and the
heritage team have looked again
at the entirety of the proposal and
their official view is what is on paper
before you
as part of this application i'll leave
it there um
i also have emails that i know that have
gone to lobbying that are from me to the
highways authority because i have
discussions with the highways authority
on various things
again everything i write is transparent
i don't have a problem with that at all
but it comes down to what is the
official view and what is the internal
workings of an application
in this case i did request highways at
the time of the last application for the
free houses
to consider if there was any way they
can remove the markings
out of the front of the public house and
this is because it was
suggested by the local member and others
that those markings would be detrimental
to the conservation area
as it was the highways authority did
agree
that they were unnecessary and agreed
they weren't needed
and therefore they were removed from
that particular proposal
at that time as it was it got refused
anyway on design grounds
however that's where that was so i don't
think there's a lot to gain from that
but i did want to put that on record
because i think it's appropriate
i will say though that this is not
community space this is a private public
space for a beer garden it is not open
to the public to use at their will
it is only at the discretion of the
owner of the land who lets
them use that land for various uses it's
not like a public sports area or
anything like that
um and waste collection was another
point
ultimately a bin storage area is
provided on plan
indeed a waste disposal lorry will not
be able to get down there just like it
doesn't get down there for the current
pub
um it would have to then you'd have to
bring those bins
forward on bin day and you'd have to
return them when it's not bin day
that's all thank you thank you
uh right where are we uh i think
are there any other questions for the
for the ward member
uh if there aren't we will then now go
into debate uh does anyone want to speak
councillor passmore thank you um
chairman um
i've listened very carefully to the
arguments i actually just want to um
personally put on record i hope nobody
thought i was criticizing any of the
analysis or the officers there it wasn't
that at all
but it's very important as i think the
planning manager john has said
we are looking at the application we
have and i
have a view um hence my question to the
ward member
this is a particularly sensitive site
and
the officers will give their
professional opinions of how they see
things that's that is their role and
they're entitled to their view and so on
just as we are
i really do wonder because it is such a
sensitive site it is in a conservation
area
um i don't know how many years it has
been a conservation area but
for as long as i can remember and mrs
alton has been a counselor even longer
than you and i have
um and it goes back many many years and
i think we need to be very very
mindful of any decision we make to take
all these factors into account
and i do wonder chairman whether it
would be sensible
um to have a site visit i know we don't
generally do them
but because it is so sensitive and i do
think people need to look at the bend on
the road
highways have their views that they've
put down i personally
am skeptical of what they've said but
that's what they've said and i think
there would be real merit in actually
having a look at the site so i'd like to
formally
propose that um others may disagree
but that's what i would like to propose
thank you for that proposal just before
we
listen to any other members can i just
ask one question
did has i know during covid and
lockdowns
officers have not been visiting site do
we know whether the highways officer
actually has attended site
i can't confirm that either way that's
for the county's risk assessment
i don't know if they ever haven't no and
during kobe they certainly
haven't been attending site so i
i think i hear what you say sorry robert
you want to come in yeah sorry chair i'd
um just with regards to cyprus to just
give members a bit more information
if that's um because on the baby side we
have
well the site visit for paper starts in
an hour and 15 minutes today so we have
a um protocol in place
whereby a risk assessment is carried out
by the chief planning officer
just to add to this point that there is
a process in place to ensure members
safety is we're still
um uh ensuring that web safety through
the covered um protocols that are still
laid out by government
um so that there is a what happens is
the chief planning officer will do a
risk assessment
and then they'll consult with the chair
and when to have the meeting
and that's involving the community so
the ward member is consulted the
community consulted on the different
issues that could come up from different
covered issues on that i just want to
give a little bit of clarity
and assurance to members that if they do
go on a service that it will be
conducted in a covert secure manner
thank you thank you
i do we have any other comments from any
of the other councillors
i certainly i think i think my personal
view and i normally do that at the end
but my personal view i think i agree
with you tim
i think this one is probably such a
unique
case and i
i think frankly we don't it's like we
tend to not do site visits lightly
it tends to need to be they need to be
fruitful in terms of what what
information they'll give to us
but i think there are a few unanswered
questions here such as the
economic development issue the ecology
issue and also
has that is that highways issue actually
what does that look like on the ground i
think i would certainly find that
helpful
to physically physically look at that uh
to certainly help with with with my
determination here but i'll be guided by
other members john was first and then
i think the short way to put it is i
largely agree with
what tim and yourself said
i really don't like kicking the can
along the road on these
things it it feels profoundly
uncomfortable
but there is the highway issue that is
questionable to my mind it's clearly
that their advice has
been revised shall we put it that way
made less honest in time
there's clearly the economic development
aspects which
i think i said before concerning me
significantly
we want to maintain the viability of
pubs as
social centers particularly and
and i thought the mppf did have
three conditions to sustainability one
of which was
who was economic um i'm concerned about
the heritage
issues again something that doesn't
always worry me greatly
but these are large buildings in
an environment which we don't see that
clearly from our maps and
and photographs as as we're told there
are a number of much
smaller dwellings and maybe this is
totally in congress
so taking those things into account i'm
inclined to say i will support the
move for a side visit thank you
councillor richardson
thank you chairman i wasn't actually
going to ask her a question but it's a
sort of technical procedural question so
i'm happy to take that outside of the
meeting
um but just to comment on what we've
discussed so far
um i think there's there's certainly a
lot to be said about this this
application
um in contrast to what i mentioned
previously actually i think there's a
lot to be said about the design um the
dwellings that we're looking at
but i do accept that the location of the
site itself is of
such a controversial and contentious
nature um that a
site visitor sounds sensible so unless
it's been officially
seconded then i'd like to second the
proposal that we defer for a site visit
thank you councillor richardson does any
other counsellor wish to have any
anything to say so we have
sorry john just to wonder
because this is going to be the first
site visit we've had postcovid
um ultimately and
for different reasons i'm not going to
be available for the next month either
ultimately the normal practice
previously was that the site visit
used to be held the following week and
it used to be then returned to
then look at that is not going to be the
process we have to go through
we have to look at the risk assessment
first
and it is only on the qualification of
that that we will allow it or not
to take place so that is the first point
the second point is then the timing of a
site visit would probably take some time
to organize
i think you're looking at at least a
month to do that
and then to return the item to committee
i suspect that needs to be scheduled
specifically so that may be some time
before it returns
i'm not saying that's a problem for you
to consider but it is timings that you
may
want to be aware of thank you thank you
for that clarification
i i agree the the time scale i mean
there are probably risks that we are
running by extending the time scale
we're fully aware that any applicant can
appeal for non-determination if we hit a
certain
target and threshold etcetera i
certainly feel in this
circumstance if we're unsure as to
whether the highest office has been
there or not
we've had interesting advice from
highways officers uh
in the past some of which has has been
questionable at times
is nothing wrong if we feel unsure that
we
make sure by having a look i certainly
have a
issue with highway safety here i
certainly have a concern with the height
if i visit site and a able to walk into
that site
looking at the height of those proposed
buildings may well completely dispel
that
that concern but at the moment these are
significantly larger buildings than the
average home uh we're in a sensitive
area here
i i think we we deserve even on that
that
that count alone because equally i
wouldn't want to
support an approval if i wasn't
fairly sure here i also wouldn't want to
try and sustain a refusal
if indeed it could be accepted perfectly
adequately on that site
so i think we owe it to everyone
concerned here to
pursue a site visit if we can i
certainly make myself
uh available whenever that's needed
because i think
such as the gravity of the circumstances
if we get any element of this
wrong councillor richardson thank you uh
chair apologies i'm now going to ask my
technical question just because it
follows on from what john's talking
about
um i just wanted to query because i'm
here as a substitute and not normally a
member of the committee
and but by virtue of the fact that i've
been the one sitting here and listening
to the debates
would it be necessary for me to attend
the site visit and in the subsequent
committee meeting or would it be
appropriate for councillor humphreys
it would normally be those that attend
that committee
so you wouldn't be expected unless you
were going new you are going to
substitute that person on the day
correct see my 18 years of experience
worked in one element so are we now
content as to that we have a motion
proposed
and seconded sure if it's helpful i can
read out what i
i've got as a um please vote as the um
promotion um i have embellished it
slightly to just
reflect the points that i raised earlier
with regards to
the cover protocol so the proposal
as i've written it is that the site
visit be undertaken of application dc
2102
94 after a risk assessment is undertaken
by the chief
planning officer in consultation with
the chair and other
parties identified in the covert secure
site visit protocol
and as previously previously mentioned
those other parties are the parish
council and the ward member
i think that's correct isn't it john
there's no other specifically identified
ones
just want to check before
no that's that's correct so as long as
that's acceptable to the proposal and
secondary
and and for those of you not been on a
site visit i've not been on a
mid-subject site visit for
a number of years i don't think they are
literally for information gathering only
they are not
there when you are there to express
opinion and it's not
a chance for people to lobby you it's a
chance for people to give you
information and points of fact uh so are
we happy to go to the vote on this now
mr carmichael i'm just to comment
i know it's when mems of the public of
austin we've always said haven't we that
it's an unwritten rule and mid-suffolk
that when a deferment goes back to the
same committee
a or b and of course we we've got an
unusual set of circumstances today where
this committee's membership is reduced
and unusually different
but we still have two regular members
here and i imagine
officers will endeavor to have a b
committee deal with this
so that i mean we'll have at least
i would have thought i would have
naturally thought if committee b is
recommending a site visit they're not
recommending it for committee a
so i would i was assuming it would be us
and this committee that would be
attending the site visit
thank you for that with that are we
ready to and happy to go to the vote
thank you chair i will now start the
vote for members that is now
showing in progress in the modern.cover
app and we'll show in light blue color
it will be at the bottom of the screen
so if members
could scroll down it will show there
council stream can i take your vote
verbally please
i will vote in favor of going on a site
visit in this
application thank you councillor
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is six votes for
and is unanimous thank you thank you all
uh
and the next item on the agenda is have
we got any insight inspections
well yes we have uh and we will be
setting the date for that
when we've when we've done the risk
assessment and realized it could be
safer or concerned
uh anything else to report from the
governance officer uh chair just a
report with the site visits one that's
any that have been requested by other
members so there's none that have been
requested by anyone else
in the council so it does and
with that at 12 53 i will officially
close the meeting and thank you for your
patience today thank you